Ich bin hier im Nintendo Headquarters in Kyoto in einem 7. Aber hier ist etwas, das ziemlich zuviel ist. Es ist ziemlich wenig bekannt.
Warte, das ist kein Packer, das sieht aus wie jemand.
Wir haben ein unidentifiziertes Flieger. Es ist ein langes, schmaler Schaft.
Ich wurde von dem enormen Flieger...
Roddi?
Hallo.
Unser Joker. Gar kein Roddi da.
Gar kein Roddi da?
Nee, der Witz geht total nach hinten los.
Aber einen Robb haben wir da.
Ja, wir haben einen Robb da.
Guten Tag.
Hallo Robb, du bist der Gast heute.
Ja, ich muss das doch mal Loch überbrücken.
Genau, das ist nämlich weit aufgerissen. Denis hat uns heute auch den Laufpass gegeben. Denis, das war's.
Aber ich bin auch noch da.
Aber Hucke ist ja noch da. Genau.
Hier ist immer wieder ein bisschen Platz drin.
Und Max ist auch da. Endlich wieder Platz zum Atmen. Apropos Atmen, hier müssen wir noch mal eine kleine Anti-Atmen-Maßnahme ergreifen. Ja, ich sehe schon Robb, du bewirbst dich hier schon für Denis Nachfolge. Gut, fangen wir doch mal hier mit dem Gast an. Also Robb, hallo, wie bist du denn? Erzähl mal.
Ja, ich bin im weitesten Sinne ein Kollege von Max. Also von mir wird oft gedacht, dass ich mit Max zusammenarbeite. Tue ich aber nur indirekt. Weil Max arbeitet ja bei Next Big Thing und ich arbeite bei Soundcloud.
Genau, wir sind komplett unterschiedliche Firmen, ich hab keine Ahnung, wer er ist.
Ich sehe den Mann zum ersten Mal. Aber Next Big Things sind Untermieter und wir teilen uns quasi einen Aufenthaltsraum. Im wesentlichen Schreibtisch. Ja, einen erweiterten Schreibtischbereich. Genau, und da arbeite ich an den iOS-Apps und an der Mac-App.
Also bist du ein Mac-Hacker auch.
Und er macht so geile Sachen wie dieses In-Uni-Code, von dem ich mal so geschwärmt habe hier. Das hat Rob zum Beispiel gemacht.
Das hab ich auch gemacht.
Diese kleine lustige Webseite, wo man Unicode-Springs rein oder raus tun kann. Wie war das nochmal?
Sowohl als auch. Ich hab gestern erst mitbekommen, es gibt Minidisc im Unicode als Emoji. Also minidisc.inunico.de Und dann sieht man eine kleine Minidisc.
Da gibt's für alles ein Subdomain.
Ich hoffe jetzt du hast die richtige Front installiert. Ansonsten siehst du nüscht.
Minidisc was wie wo?
In uni.
Hammer.
Und das kannst du jetzt in deinem Tweet kopieren.
Ist aber irgendwie pixelig.
Da kann ich nichts mehr. Aber das kann ich ja in San Francisco mal anwerken.
Wie kommt denn da so ein Bild?
Das ist ein Emoji.
Was machen die da jetzt mit Line?
Das ist ein Buchstabe.
Wie auf dem iPhone.
Nur ganz weit hinten.
Ein Buchstabe, der wiederum aus Bitmap ist. Aber jetzt haben wir Jahrzehnte dafür gefochten, Vector Funds zu bekommen und jetzt durch die Hintertür, durch die Japaner.
Durch die Japaner?
Das ist die Rache der Japaner, weil die waren ja sehr lange nicht glücklich mit Unicode.
Very pranely furnished.
Ich kenne auch noch andere Leute, die nicht glücklich sind mit Unicode.
Aber die Japaner, die wollten es ja lange nicht so richtig. Oder die Asiaten generell.
Ach so, wieso wollten sie das nicht haben?
Na, weil da fehlt... Also ich habe ja mal mit Mats gesprochen, mit Yukihiro Matsumoto, dem großen Erfinder der Programmiersprache Ruby, dessen Apfelsinenschale ich schon mal anfassen durfte.
Nein!
Apfelsinenschale, das übertragende Begriff?
Nein, ich kann keine Apfelsinenschale auch mal anfassen. Oder mein Roddy.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich ihn mal gefragt. Bei Ruby war das halt auch lange Zeit so ein Second Class Citizen. Und er meinte, naja, das haben sich halt Amerikaner ausgedacht. Und die hatten halt keine Ahnung von asiatischen Sprachen. Und da waren halt ganz viele Mappings einfach kaputt oder falsch.
Na, die haben irgendwie diese Han-Unification gemacht, wo sie die chinesischen, koreanischen und japanischen Character übereinkommen geschert haben.
Also es war halt so, wenn du sozusagen einmal den Roundtrip gemacht hast von irgendwas nach, was ich war, die haben, wie heißt der in Coding, der eigentlich ist? Was?
Da fraßt mich zu viel.
Genau, wenn du das halt einmal von da nach Unicode und wieder zurückgemacht hast, dann kam halt nicht das gleiche raus, lange Zeit.
Nein.
Und deswegen fanden die Japaner im speziellen und wahrscheinlich auch alle Asiaten Unicode erstmal richtig scheiße.
Und das hätten wir genauso scheiße gefunden. Mein Gott, die Amerikaner haben sich doch schon mit den europäischen Schriftsystemen schon komplett verbrannt.
Auf jeden Fall hat das dann eine ganze Weile gedauert und die Asiaten haben alle rumgeningelt und irgendwann war es dann aber drin und jetzt ist das wahrscheinlich die Rache dafür. So jetzt haben jetzt hören sie auf uns jetzt. Jetzt drücken wir in ganz viele dämliche Bitmaps von Rache der Asiaten. Bitmaps von Kackhaufen rein.
Aber ja, mittlerweile...
Und ja, wir brauchen 23 verschiedene Bitmaps für Kackhaufen, ganz wichtig. Sonst nehmen wir das Unicode nämlich nicht.
Kackhaufen zu Bitmaps.
Aber irgendjemand hat auch die Domain reserviert. Es gibt da so ein paar Länder, da kann man ein Unicode-Zeichen auch nehmen, der hat kackhaufen.ny, oder ich weiß nicht was, irgendwie so was.
Naja, also falls es noch keinem aufgefallen sein sollte, das hier ist die 89. Ausgabe von Mobile Max. Der Sendung, die alle zwei Wochen vollständig verzweifelt vor der Apple-Nachrichtenlage steht und zunehmendem Maße auch vor Apple.
Aber nicht, aber immer noch nicht kapituliert.
Nee, wir geben die Hoffnung nicht auf. Aber was erhoffen wir uns eigentlich? Wir wollen eigentlich die Wiederkehr des Erlösers. Apple Ostern wollen wir haben. Genau, Zombie Steve zu Apple Ostern. Und irgendwie, dass er wiederkommt. Weil, als sich diese, wie war das nochmal? Dieses Banner, was sie jetzt da vor der WWDC ausgerollt haben. Was haben sie da drauf geschrieben?
Where do you want to go today and create wildes, wildes googeln?
Tja, iPad ist auch nicht schnell genug, alles Dreck. Where great ideas go on to do great things. Also wenn Steve noch leben würde, wär der Typ, der sich den Spruch hat einfallen lassen, bestimmt schon gefeuert worden.
Mit dem Spruch geht auch zu Microsoft.
Ich mein, das geht mir einmal noch überhaupt nicht von der Zunge. Puckel, sag's nochmal, wie war's? Ich mein, das ist doch eine Microsoft Überschrift.
Oh Gott! Schlimmer fast sogar. Also sogar Microsoft hat catchige, also griffigere Headlines hinbekommen. So scheiße wie der Spruch ist, aber man hat sich eingeregt.
Panic hatte das, hatte die Domänen, diese kackhaufen Domänen. Kackhaufen.la Pooler.
Können wir vielleicht den Fäkalanteil ein bisschen reduzieren? Das bekommt mir alles nicht nach dem Essen. Ich hab ja auch noch.
Brownies. Das darfst du dir nur anbieten, wenn du das richtige Emoji dafür findest. Da gibt es Brownie.
Ich hab wirklich Brownies hier. Original NSFW Brownies.
Wie ist die Dosierung so? Gut.
Die ist gut.
Halbes Gramm, Drittel?
Wir können mal erwähnen, wer UTF8 auch noch nicht so mag.
Das sind unsere Freunde bei Apple.
Das sind unsere Freunde bei Apple, die die Batches drucken.
Max und ich waren ja zur WWDC am Freitag im Coco Plane.
Hell yeah.
Im Coco Plane?
Lufthansa 454?
Wieso ist das der Coco Plane?
Weil es von Objective-C gesteuert wird.
Ihr habt das nachträglich so genannt, weil ihr festgestellt habt, dass viele andere damit auch fliegen?
Wenn das Flugzeug abstürzt, dann ist die deutsche iOS-Entwicklerszene dezimiert.
Genau, aber... Die Podcast-Landschaft wahrscheinlich auch.
Hier Brownies. Ihr kennt euch was. Sehr lecker.
Und ich hab das...
Wann sind die angekommen?
Das zweifelhafte Vergnügen.
Die sind gar nicht angekommen, die hab ich selber gemacht. Ja, nach dem originalen NSFW-Brownie-Rezept. Das sind schon viele Leute. Ordentlich.
Jetzt lass mal was fertig erzählen.
Also, ich hab ja das zweifelhafte Vergnügen, einen Umlaut in meinem Nachnamen zu haben. Und damit kommt Apple gar nicht klar. Und jetzt kann man sich da einloggen bei der WWDC und kriegt seine Badge-Information angezeigt, wo dann der Firmenname drauf steht und der eigene Name. Und da hab ich dann nur so ein großes, also mein Nachname ist Böhnke, B-Ö-H-N-K-E. Und da steht dann...
B Schneemann.
Nee, B.
Ein großes A mit so einer Zähle drüber. Und dann umgekehrtes Paragrafenzeichen.
Der Klassiker.
Und dann H-N-K-E. Und dann hab ich da mal den E-Mail geschrieben und gesagt, äh, so nicht.
21. Jahrhundert. Das ist so traurig.
Ist geil, oder?
I understand that your name is Robert Bointke and it is appearing to be garbled. The reason you are seeing your surname garbled is due to the O with the umlaut on top.
Our systems do not support those characters.
Was hiermit eindeutig bewiesen wäre.
I can update your name to Robert Bointke if that's sufficient.
Was?
Das Apple für dich.
Wenn Steve das wüsste.
Ach, das war jahrelang mit Steve auch so.
Jetzt haben sie meinen Namen geupdatet und dann kommt das, die neue Geburtsurkunde kommt wahrscheinlich demnächst in der Post.
Wenn da jemand draußen zuhört und über so kyrostatische Einfräher kammert und so, ja, also ich wäre interessiert daran, das 21. Jahrhundert einfach zu überspringen und einfach direkt um 22. aufzuwachen in der Hoffnung, dass sich jemand da besser hat.
Wenn du um das Aufwachen rausgehst, schaffst Apple mittlerweile UTF-8-off-Batches?
Nein. Also, es geht nicht.
Das ist absoluter ASCII-Faschismus, den die da betreiben.
Ihr ein anderer Kollege, der hat tatsächlich schon seit Jahren seinen Nachnamen mit Umlaut deswegen geändert auf deren Badge, weil sie haben es einfach über Jahre, sie krampfen es noch nie hin.
Und jetzt haben sie auf der Profil-Seite, wo man seine Daten eingetragen hat, oben so eine Zeile reingetragen, ja, hier bitte keinen diakritischen Zeichen in seinem Nachnamen haben und dann lieber Transliteration benutzen.
Es ist ein Wunder, dass sie überhaupt Developer zulassen in ihrem Programm.
Ja, die hätten mich auch detaillieren können.
Wir dürfen ihnen die Regel leider nicht sagen, aufgrund dessen sie abgelehnt wurden. Aber kleiner Tipp, benennen sie sich doch um.
Wir haben auch mal nachgeguckt im UTF-8-Konsortium, in dem Gründerteam oder wer auch immer, da war nicht einer mit irgendwelchen Sonderzeichen im Namen.
Da ist eine Russin drin, aber die ist komplett askifiziert worden.
Oh, dieses... Das ist so traurig.
Wir waren mal Fans von dieser Firma. Erinnerst du dich noch, Hucke?
Ich immer noch, ich immer noch, ich immer noch.
Echt?
Ist dir jetzt eigentlich krass drin in den Brownies oder nicht? Nein, nein. Die Wände schmelzen schon wieder.
Die sind aber ganz okay.
Also echt, also wirklich, also nee.
Wieso hast du den einen Elefanten auf dem Kopf, Bax?
Ja, und das Ding ist halt...
Nicht so viele Witze über Drogen machen. Wir müssen Freitag noch durch die TSA durch.
Ja, zieht euch frische Unterhosen an, ne?
Am besten mit Eingriff.
Ich hab meine eigenen Latex-Handschuhe mitgebracht.
Jetzt lachen wir noch.
Aber es ist in San Francisco, ich hab gehört, da ist das alles ein bisschen entspannter.
Es gibt übrigens auch eine Schmatztasse auf euren tollen Femdkons.
Ah, die macht das Schmatzen lauter.
Erst braun nichts verteilen, dann aufregen, dass wir geschmatzen.
Das ist ein dezenter Hinweis, im Sinne der Hörer.
Im Sinne der Hörer?
Wir müssen ja noch Platz lassen für den richtigen Content in den Kommentaren, dass dann alles nur wieder sich über das Thema dreht. Für Flatter haben wir auch noch in dieser Sendung Platz gelassen. Heute ja alles gut, habe ich beschlossen.
Soll ich mit Spielzeugen anfangen?
Ne, weil wir reden ja gerade über die WWDC und dann bleiben wir jetzt auch mal bei der WWDC und den ganzen Spielzeugkram und Klimbim und dem Velova-Kram. Da stehen wir jetzt einfach mal nach hinten. So, jetzt wird hier erstmal ordentlich, wie sich das für so eine Sendung gehört, die kurz vor der WWDC stattfindet. Wird hier geglaskugelt, was das Zeug hält. Ich würde sagen, wir legen uns mal fest. Schockierte Blicke.
Also ich habe echt Angst vor einer Serie, Arpi.
Wirklich?
Also wenn die auch kommt, ist okay. Aber da gab es ja irgendwie so, hat Gruber ja so geschrieben, von wegen, dass so die ganzen TBR Sessions, dieses To Be Announced Zeug, was jetzt noch nicht bekannt ist, dass das alles Serie-Integration sein könnte und dass jetzt alle Entwickler auf Serie gedrillt werden.
Wenn du mal guckst, wo die stattfinden, die To Be Announced Apps, Labs, dann steht da halt auch, wo, und das ist dann das Graphics & Media Lab, der Raum. Das spricht schon so ein bisschen für das neue API-Geschichte.
Ja, aber ich hab keinen Bock auf Serie.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das alles Serie ist. Ich hoffe auch nicht. Ich glaube eher, dass die Maps eine große Rolle spielen. Wenn Apple Maps macht, angenommen ihr werdet Apple und ihr macht Maps. Und jetzt ist ja auch so, sie kaufen seit Jahren... Sie kaufen seit Jahren Buden ein, die da irgendwas machen. Grundsätzlich denke ich mal, so eine Infrastruktur für Kartenanzeige, das kriegen sie schon irgendwie selber gehackt. Da brauchen sie jetzt nicht unbedingt totale Mega-Experten. Aber was haben sie eingekauft, soweit man das weiß? Da sind einerseits diese C3-Bude, die halt diese schönen 3D-Sachen macht. Deswegen gehe ich mal davon aus, das Ganze wird halt gleich in so einer ordentlichen 3D-Variante kommen, die hoffentlich hübscher ist als das, was Google Earth sich nach Jahren immer noch traut auszuspucken.
Genau, aber das ist ja nichts für Developer. Da kommt dann halt den Wirkungsproler dran?
Nein, das ist nichts für Developer. Da hast du recht. Ich überlege ja nur, was machen sie mit diesen Buden? Dann haben sie noch ein paar andere, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie die hießen, was war das, PlaySpace und noch irgendwie sowas. Also ich hab immer wieder davon gehört, dass sie so kleine Firmen aufgekauft haben, die sich eben auf Location spezialisiert haben. Und ich denke mal, wenn dieses ganze Maps-Ding für sie ein sinnvolles Replacement ist, man muss ja auch schauen, was ist jetzt in Google Maps drin, was Apple komplett ersetzt. Weil in dem Moment, wo sie Google Maps rausschmeißen, schmeißen sie ja nicht nur Straßenkarten und Straßenansichten raus. Können wir uns durchaus vorstellen, dass Street View rausschlägt?
Na ziemlich sicher dann.
Fände ich zwar schade, aber häufig hab ich es nicht benutzt auf dem iPhone.
Du bist ja auch in Deutschland.
Das kommt noch dazu. Wobei ich es eigentlich immer ganz interessant finde, gerade in andere Länder sich da ein Bild zu verschaffen. Aber was für mich durchaus ein Mehrwert ist, auch wenn das durchaus noch verbesserungswürdig ist, ist eben das explizite Suchen nach Orten. Wo ist hier ein Café? Wo ist hier irgendwas? Wo ist das nächste Beerdigungsinstitut? Das sind so Dinge, die muss man manchmal wissen.
Das Beerdigungsinstitut, wie oft brauchst du das? Such mal nach Beerdigungsinstitut, mir geht's schon ein bisschen schlechter.
Ich hab nur gerade überlegt, was ich heute auf meinem Weg, als ich in der Stadt war, so an Läden gesehen habe und unter anderem...
Aber hier in dieser Maps-App gibt's keinen Street View, da muss man schon die Google...
Doch, doch, da gibt's das.
Das ist aber well hidden, du musst einen Pin haben.
Dann gehst du hier auf die, das ist Manne-Kicken drauf. Und ta-da!
Und es geht halt eigentlich auch nur davon aus, dass du eben Dinge suchst und findest. Wenn sie jetzt die Google-Ort-Suche nicht mehr verwenden, könnte ja auch sein, weiß ich nicht, könnte das sein, dass sie nicht mehr die Maps verwenden, aber die Suche von Google?
Nein, nach Locations ist vielleicht eine spannende Frage. Es gibt ja die genaue... Irgendjemand hat, ich hab dummerweise natürlich mir nicht aufgeschrieben, wer hat neulich aufgebracht, dass ja der Geo- Locator, also das Ding, was aus deinem Latitude- also aus Longitude-Latitude ne Ortsangabe macht, dass das schon seit ner ganzen Weile gar nicht mehr von Google stammen würde, sondern dass das Apple schon ausgetauscht hätte und dass man jetzt quasi schon ne ganze Weile deren Datenbank dafür verwendet. Das heißt also die Richtung aus Koordinaten Ortsangaben zu machen, ist schon von Apple. Haben wir alle gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Aber wo kriegen die denn die Daten her?
Die werden sich eingekauft haben, oder?
Na genau, da wogen sie auch hergekriegt.
Ja, aber die haben ja ne Suchmaschine noch nebenbei. Das fällt dir da so hinten runter, oder?
Ah, also...
Diese Software-Struktur bei Apple.
Deswegen muss ich das auch überhaupt erstmal ansprechen. Ich bin mir nicht so richtig sicher, was jetzt eigentlich so die Quellen sind, aber du kannst ja schon seit Jahr und Tag bei Google Maps so Orte claimen. Du kannst sagen, so hier, da ist was eingetragen und ich wohne an dieser Adresse und ich habe diesen Laden. Und dann kriegst du von Google eine Postkarte zugeschickt an die Adresse mit einem Freischaltcode und dann owns du das.
Ich hab auch angerufen werden, ja.
Ach so kriegt man das hin.
Ja, ich own übrigens immer noch das BCC auf Google Maps. Ich kann das jetzt nicht übertragen, weil das irgendwie nicht vorgesehen ist.
Wie, aber das kannst du ja jetzt machen?
Nein, kannst du halt die Öffnungszeiten ändern.
Habt ihr das eingetragen?
Ich dachte mal, ich kläre das mal, bevor das irgendjemand anders macht. Das war eher aus Freundlichkeit und hatte dann nicht bedacht. Also ich wusste überhaupt nicht, ich habe das mal ausprobiert. Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, wie dieser Prozess funktioniert. Danach wusste ich es halt. Es klebt in meinem Account und ist nicht vorgesehen, dass man das von einem Account auf den anderen transferiert. Vielleicht ist das mittlerweile vorgesehen, aber ich habe diese Funktion nie gefunden.
Weil so Orte ja auch nie den Besitzer wechseln.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Oder überhaupt mal vielleicht auch andere Leute zuständig sind oder keine Ahnung.
Aber kann man umlaut den Namen verwenden?
Das hat Google tatsächlich, glaube ich, hinbekommen.
Nur wenn da so arme Tilde drin ist.
Beim Kollegen ist es noch schlimmer. Der ist Brasilianer und der wurde mittlerweile schon zweimal irgendwie durchenkodiert. Und der Name wird immer länger, weil natürlich immer mehr Charaktere zu kommen.
Dann sollten wir uns lieber mit Apple beschäftigen. Ach, war ja Apple. Mir schmerzt wirklich das Hirn. So, zurück zu diesen Maps und diesen TBD-Räumen. Also, angenommen, sie machen das jetzt alles selbst. Uns bleibt gar nichts übrig von Google Maps. Und auch gar nichts von überhaupt irgendeinem Google. Außer vielleicht der normalen...
Ich würde sagen, wir können auch fest von ausgehen. Nach diesem Maps-Event hier von Google gerade, das die mal davor geschoben haben und so, das ist... Jetzt können wir davon ausgehen, dass das Ding ist durch. Und ich meine, Google Maps auf dem iPhone, es ist ja schon seit Jahren deutlich schlechter. Also ich meine, wir haben da eine Suche und wir haben Karten und das ist auch alles okay, ich find's auch, aber Android hat schon seit Jahren Vektor-Maps, also die wesentlich schneller laden, die haben hier Navigation, also Turn-by-Turn-Navigation im Betriebssystem drinnen, die haben, ach weiß ja teufel was, noch alles, diese Layer, dass man so diese Ebenen drüberlegen kann, dieses ganze Zeug. Also da fehlt schon einiges, so bei der entsprechenden Apple-Version. Also das muss dringend, da muss was passieren.
Ja, das ist so. Und deswegen denke ich, dass an der Stelle zumindest da auch neue APIs entstehen, wie du diese Orte da auch populiert bekommst und wie du auch diese Orte rauskriegst. Also ich denke, sie werden ein sehr hohes Interesse daran haben, ihre Apps auf dem Smartphone mit diesem Kram zu befüllen. Weil sowas gibt es ja derzeit noch nicht in iOS, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also du kannst zwar in dieser Maps-Applikation dir anzeigen lassen, dass da Café Bim Bam ist, aber du kannst ja nicht über eine iOS-API sagen, sag mir mal, was hier ist. Oder? Gibt es sowas?
Ich glaube nicht.
Habe ich auch noch nicht von gehört. Aber ich wäre überhaupt nicht die Bohne überrascht, wenn sowas eben auch einen ganz großen Anteil hat. Also es überhaupt sie quasi so eine neue Generation von Location-Based Services einleiten, die halt wirklich so real world sind. Die nicht irgendwie nur so, ich stehe jetzt hier und ich kann abspeichern, wo ich bin und ich sehe vielleicht noch Leute, die im Umkreis von 500 Metern sind und hurra und find my friends, sondern halt so the real shit. Und natürlich fangen sie erstmal an, wieder nur USA und dann irgendwie im September dann auch Deutschland und so, das übliche Spiel. Also so ein schrittweiser Rollout. Und da sind viele Fragen offen, vor allem auch, welche Rolle spielt Open Street Map in dem Zusammenhang? Haben sie da irgendwelche Proposals? Schieben sie morgen wieder 8 GB Open Source Update für OSM, woran sie jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre gearbeitet haben und bei OSM ist nur ein einziger eingeweiht worden, der aber schon seit zwei Wochen geknebelt irgendwie in Cupertino im Keller sitzt, bis er irgendwie rausgelassen werden darf und sagen kann, dass er davon wusste oder wahrscheinlich das noch nicht mal.
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass sie da so auf den Open Street Map Zug aufspringen, so sehr ich mir das eigentlich wünschen würde, aber...
Warum nicht?
Das ist nett für dich, ne?
Wenn sie sowas machen, dann kaufen sie sich ja meistens die Dudes irgendwie selber ein, so wie bei Coops oder... Was war der andere?
Ja, aber die Daten...
Ich weiß nicht, wie leicht das ist, oder... Das ist eben...
Das Ding ist halt... Also Open Street Map, die benutzen ja immer noch so... Was heißt immer noch, aber ihre Architektur ist ja relativ bescheiden, ne? Da haben wir jetzt so einen Postgres mit PostGIS-Extension, ein mega riesen Datenset, dann halt verschiedene Renderer dafür, aber das ist halt schon alles...
Vielleicht machen sie das so wie mit WebKit. Morgen gibt's irgendwie OSMKit. Ja, wir haben das mal alles neu geschrieben, GeoKit, WorldKit. Oder einfach nur Kit mit Doppel-T.
Also so oder so... Also ich mein, Apple wird da nicht die Daten sozusagen in Open Street Map lassen, die würden ja dann so oder so wahrscheinlich ihren eigenen Mirror erfahren. Also...
Na, sie werden sicherlich nicht auf die OSM-Server zugreifen. Das ist klar.
Also sie haben die Daten schonmal selber. Und dann, weiß ich nicht, ob... Also dann noch wieder... Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie klingt es nicht so plausibel für mich.
Also ich würde sagen, die machen dann wahrscheinlich so was wie so eine Übergangsphase mit Open Street Maps Daten in Regionen, wo sie selber noch nichts haben. Sowas kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Die machen keine Übergangsphase. Die haben jetzt nicht drei Jahre die Füße stillgehalten, um dann irgendwie mit einer Übergangsphase zu starten. Die haben das Ding komplett geplant. Und entweder...
Na, die machen gut einen Amerika-Start.
Oder haben sie geübt.
Hoffentlich Amerika und Europa und Asien so ein bisschen. Aber die ganzen restlichen Regionen, wo sie keine Karten haben, wäre jetzt so meine Vermutung.
Die haben noch hier noch Kohle.
Wo die Siri-Daten herkommen? Du kannst ja Siri in Amerika zumindest fragen. Erfinde mir eine Starbucks.
Von Yelp. Ja klar, die kooperieren einfach. Die kooperieren nicht mehr. Klar, die machen das mit Yelp zusammen.
Da haben sie die Daten ja im Prinzip.
Genau, da haben sie die schon.
Richtig.
Und das machen sie dann vielleicht hier auch noch. Und Yelp führt sich wahrscheinlich von Google so übergang, dass sie halt mit Apple in die Kiste steigen. Und glücklich sind, dass noch jemand ihre Daten haben will.
Kann in Syrien, mittlerweile auch in Deutschland, irgendwelche nennenswerten Auskünfte, kann ich hier auch sagen, irgendwie Fettuccini, einmal Lasagna, Bolognese, la la la? Hast du ein 4S? Frag mal, wo ihr der nächste Italiener ist.
Where's the nearest Italian place?
Auf Englisch ist ja geschummelt, ne?
Ich hab's auf Englisch gestellt.
Jaja. Das muss er ja verstehen, wenn's Deutsch ist.
Scheiße, ich bin hier wieder.
Können wir mal was Geiles, was Robb gemacht hat, zum Thema Siri zeigen?
Lass uns mal lieber beim Thema bleiben. Du lenkst immer ab.
Ich lenk gar nicht ab. Das passt jetzt gerade gut rein.
Nein, nein, du lenkst ab. Wir sind bei Geo-Services. Können Sie das gerne merken, Siri, alles kein Problem. Was könnten die TBD-Räume noch sein? Außer Siri und außer All Things Maps? Ist das eine Vermutung, ein Tipp oder eine Möglichkeit?
Ich vermute es einfach, weil die ersten TBD-Labs sind schon am Dienstag und wenn am Montag die Keynote ist, dann muss ja irgendwas sein, wo alle Leute sofort Fragen haben.
Ja, aber bei den Maps haben sie bestimmt alle sofort Fragen.
Ja, aber das ist so viel und Maps brennt niemand so unter den Nägeln.
Da kommt drauf an, was sie da annunzen. Ich meine, wenn du da irgendwie...
Map-Apps. Map-Apps.
In welchem Maße du dich da in diese Maps mit einklinken kannst?
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sie da eine Menge einbauen. Also ich kann schon, wenn die da vernünftige APIs machen, die mehr können als bisher, dann könnte Maps plötzlich für alle ein spannendes Thema sein.
Das kommt auf jeden Fall mehr als jetzt nur ein Replacement für die App, was genau dasselbe macht.
Ich meine, Navigation passt natürlich ganz gut zu dem WWDC-Slogan mit Where Ideas Go.
Das ist nicht zu fassen. Das ist eine Frechheit. Eine Frechheit den Gläubigen gegenüber.
Was waren denn so bisherigen WWDC-Slogan?
Hatten sie überhaupt welche außer irgendwelche Alkons?
Sie haben immer schon so Slogans gehabt.
Redmond, start your photocopiers.
Und es waren immer so ganz dezente Andeutungen, was dann so eigentlich der Knaller war, vielleicht.
Vielleicht red ich mir das jetzt aus.
Also wirklich gut waren die auch nicht immer.
Können uns der Chat da vielleicht mal helfen ein paar WWDC-Slogans der letzten Jahre auszugraben? Ihr seid doch da immer ganz finde ich. Ah, der war ja...
Ja, aber Apple TV ist irgendwie... Stimmt, das ist auch irgendwie fällig. Das ist jetzt nach dem... Da muss was kommen. Also ich meine, das ist jetzt so oft geleakt und weiß der Teufel was und das wäre echt peinlich. Oder muss nicht dieses Mal sein, aber irgendwann wird da was kommen. Und die Uhr! Die Uhr muss man ja alle programmieren, ne? Die Uhr? Ich hab ja mein Dauer-Ding hier, dass ich sage, Apple bringt noch mal eine Uhr raus. So was wie diese... Wie heißt die Uhr, die sie jetzt hier alle verkauft haben? Diese Pebble-Uhr. So was in der Richtung nur in besser.
Die haben sie schon verkauft?
Naja, nee, also hier mit Kickstarter. Kickstarter konntest du schon kaufen, kannst ja schon investieren.
Ja.
Das wird ein böses Aufwachen geben, wenn die nachher scheiße ist.
Ich bin mir da ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so sicher, ob da nicht vielleicht tatsächlich was kommt. In der Richtung.
Ich bleib jetzt einfach dabei. Ich hab das jetzt so lange behauptet, noch lächerlicher kann ich mich da nicht machen.
Das stimmt, da bist du natürlich gut dran.
Ah, ich hab's im App-Kit gefunden.
Ich muss mal kurz eure komischen...
Und der Coco Touch layer.
Na gut, letztes Jahr war jetzt...
Dann fehlt es da wirklich nicht los.
Mein Mac Pro spinnt schon wieder rum. Ja, in der Tat, das wird jetzt sozusagen auch Zeit. Ich hab hier so ein kleines Bluetooth-Überlastungsproblem, glaube ich. Sind eure Devices noch an? Nee, ist nämlich alles tot. Genau, das ganze Bluetooth ist nämlich jetzt auf dieser Küste gerade abgestürzt. Den Effekt hatte ich schon mal und das auf eine Art und Weise.
Und ich schmatze hier die ganze Zeit und denke, niemand hört das.
Jaja, das ist vorbei jetzt gerade. Und das Geile ist, dass ich das jetzt nur beheben kann, indem ich diese Kiste reboote, was ich natürlich jetzt nicht tun kann.
Ich glaube, ich bringe mir mal so ein Bier. Hinten noch jemand ein Bier?
Ja, ich bringe mal so ein Bier.
Er hat jetzt der Meinung, er hat gar keinen Bluetooth mehr. Also das Kontrollpanel taucht noch nicht mal mehr auf. Jetzt versteht man dich nicht, wenn du durch die Gegend gehst, ne? Ach, ist das alles beknackt.
Es geht back up.
Ja, ich meine, solche Probleme existieren und sie wagen es überhaupt, eine neue Developer-Konferenz anzukündigen. Ich prangere das an. Ich prangere das an. So, gibt es irgendwelche Rückmeldungen bezüglich der...
WWDC-Slogans?
Nee, die anderen waren wahrscheinlich auch alle blöd. It simply works? Nein.
Join us for a preview of the future of iOS and Mac OS X.
Ah, naja, okay. Das kann man sich wenigstens merken.
Kurz und knackig.
Evolutionär quasi.
Was steht hier? Es gibt neue WWDC-TV-Spots auf der Apple-Webseite. Ist das wahr?
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe.
Ja, ich versuche gerade mal das herauszufinden, aber irgendwie...
Max sägt erstmal einen Bierkasten in der Zwischenzeit.
Was ist denn das für ein exklusives Bier?
Hörerbier. Selbst gebraut. Ja, also werden dann Tim das Bluetooth repariert und Max den Bierkasten zersägt.
Ich hatte das Problem, dass ich jetzt gerade mit meinem 11 Zoll meinen 27 Zoll Fernsteuer muss, das ist ein bisschen carnifelig. Du könntest mir mal diese Tastatur da...
Na, bei dir.
Vielleicht mal...
Genau.
Hat er vergessen, dass er Bluetooth hat. Das hatte ich bei meinem Macbook Pro mal. Das war sehr, sehr nervig.
Tja, so ist das. Alles ist nicht mehr zuverlässig hier. Das kann an diesem Osculator liegen, den ich hier irgendwie habe. Weil der halt da irgendwie so auf Treiberebene reingeht und ich glaube, der nagelt ihm irgendwie das Bluetooth weg. Da ist glaube ich mal ein kleiner Bugreport fällig.
Diese Magic Mouse hat übrigens auch Bluetooth, ne?
Ja, ich weiß. Die könnte ich nämlich jetzt auch gar nicht perden ohne Bluetooth.
Na, jetzt hast du keine kabelgebundene.
Ich glaube, wir müssen gleich mal so eine Maus mit Kabel bestellen. Mach mal oder Maus? Mal schauen, wie schnell die liefern.
Ich habe mir auch eine zum Diablo-Spielen eine Maus gekauft, weil meine Hand weh getan hat.
Hast du die dabei?
Nee, aber könnte ich zum nächsten Mal arrangieren.
Hast du vorher mit Touchpad gespielt?
Nee, mit Magic Mouse, aber die Magic Mouse ist eigentlich, also zum Gelegenheitsklicken ist okay, aber nicht zum so richtig Dauerklicken, ja, und vor allen Dingen nicht so wie bei Diablo. Und ja, da musste auch mal eine andere Maus her. Kann ich nächste Mal mitbringen.
Ich komme eigentlich ganz gut klar mit Diablo und der Magic Mouse.
Nein, bei mir, also meine Hände, weiß nicht, die sind relativ, nicht klein zumindest, und dann hat man es halt so, habe ich meinen Mittelfinger eigentlich immer in der Luft, weil ich halt nicht rechts klicken will aus Versehen. Und dadurch verspann sich das alles so. Also ich habe halt Touch sowieso, Klick und so weiter, das ist ja furchtbar. Und dabei, der kann jetzt halt beide Finger drauf liegen lassen und hat ja den physikalischen Klick dadurch und deswegen. Jetzt hab ich mir die SteelSeries Sensei geholt, so heißt die. Das ist halt so voll die Gamer-Maus, kann man sich irgendwie...
Leuchtet die im Dunkeln?
Die Leuchte kann man auch ausschalten wieder. Und man kann sich halt, kann man alles mögliche tunen. Das ist eine Laser-Maus, hat halt super hohe Auflösungen, kann man irgendwie einstellen, wie hoch die Auflösung des Sensors sein soll, kann man sich Makros programmieren, kann man einstellen, ob er Pfadkorrektur machen soll. Also wenn du halt kreise und geraden ziehen willst, ja dann, ob er die ausgleichen soll oder ob du, es gibt halt so Sachen in diesen Maustreibern, dann, wenn du halt anfängst, zum Beispiel Counter-Strike oder sowas zu spielen und du rennst halt rum die ganze Zeit, macht da nichts. Und wenn du dann in so einem Threshold landest, wo du nur ganz wenig deine Maus bewegst, weil du gerade zielst oder so, dann schalten sie halt so auf ultraprecise den Sensor-Resolution automatisch hoch. Damit du dann halt wirklich so pixelgenau deinen Fadenkreuz noch verschieben kannst.
Gibt es sowas auch für Photoshop?
Ja klar, bestimmt.
Weil dafür würde es doch mal Sinn machen, diese ganzen...
Das müsste im Prinzip auch da genauso funktionieren. Und hat halt hier Gold-USB-Stecker, ja.
Verkauft. Ich habe mir auch sowas.
Also die Maus ist halt auch noch... Also ich bin kein Linkshänder, aber falls man Linkshänder ist, das ist halt eine, die für beide geht. Ist halt so wie so diese klassische Microsoft-Maus eigentlich im Prinzip geformt. Und die ist ganz gut auf jeden Fall. Döfte.
Döfte.
Und ja, also die Software dafür, die gibt es natürlich eigentlich nur für Windows, aber die Maus auch in ihrer Default-Setting. Also man kann, unten ist ein Display an der Maus und man kann auch mit den Maus-Buttons über dieses super kleine Display alle Settings machen oder viele Settings, aber sie funktioniert auch im Default-Auslieferungszustand wunderbar.
Also auf dem Mac hast du das ja nicht, dieses Counter-Strike-Ziele zu erscheinen.
Doch, doch, doch, also es gibt halt Profile. Es sind schon fünf so Profile drauf gespeichert, die kannst du auswählen. Kannst auch bestimmte Settings halt tune mit der Maus selbst alleine nur mit dem Display, was unten dran ist.
Gibt es auch einen guten App-Store, wo du dir ein Diablo 3 Profil runterladen kannst.
Vielleicht, vielleicht.
Er schaltet immer noch daran die Kreditkartennummer. Es gab mal irgendwie, das habe ich mal auf der CeBIT gesehen, da bin ich nur an deren Stand vorbeigegangen, um zu gucken, dass das kein April-Scherz ist. Da hatten die eine Maus mit so, die sah so aus, als ob die so ein Rückspiegel hätte an der Seite, wo dann ein Display drin war, wo man dann irgendeine Zusatzsoftware drauf laufen lassen konnte, wo man dann drin sehen konnte, wie viele neue E-Mails man hatte.
Ah ja, die hatten wir im CCC eine ganze Zeit lang in irgendeiner Grappelbox drauf, die war so schlecht. Das war so Nokia, irgendwie so ein typisches Nokia-Display irgendwie auch, ne?
Kann sein, weiß ich. Also ich hab sie nur einmal kurz gesehen, ich hab die bei Heise gesehen und die war so scheiße. Das war auch angeguckt und nicht geglaubt, dass es wirklich nur auf den Messestand gegangen ist, um zu gucken, ob sich das irgendjemand hinstellt und ja, es hat jemand tatsächlich dieses Ding gebaut und hier hat das für eine gute Idee. Gab es jetzt irgendwelche WWDC-Spots oder?
Tim restartet noch das Bluetooth. Der hat es ja nicht mehr, weil sein Kopfhörer gar nicht mehr connected ist.
Weil der auch über Bluetooth dran ist.
Nein, nein, ich habe einfach parallel versucht hier...
Er probiert noch mal auszukaufen.
Sprich dich aus, Tim. Du kannst es nicht sagen.
Ich versuche hier gerade dieser Gerüchtelage, was neue Geräte betrifft... Herr zu werden.
Und, was kommt? Also bisher ist es ja noch nicht so tolle, ne?
Also es sieht ja nun sehr danach aus, dass es ein Update zu den Mac Pros gibt. Das ist auch nicht wirklich überraschend, beseitig man ist davon ausgegangen, dass es gar keine Mac Pros mehr geben wird. Wovon ich nicht ausgegangen bin. Und ich hoffe ja immer noch so, dass sie sich was piffiges haben einfallen lassen, was den Formfaktor betrifft. Wenn das zum Beispiel irgendwie hinkriegen das 19 Zoll Mountable zu machen.
Als X-Surf-Ersatz?
Ja, weniger als X-Surf-Ersatz, aber dass man auch, wenn man jetzt so ein Teil hat, auch einfach in so einen Rack schrauben kann. Weil das ist einfach mal praktisch. Das ist einfach eine gute Methode.
Naja, aber du könntest dir ja in deinen Rack so einen Boden reinschrauben und dann zwei nebeneinander stellen. Das hat dann halt irgendwie sechs Höhen-Einheiten vielleicht insgesamt.
Ja, wie auch immer. Also kann auch einfach sein, dass es wieder the same old shit, but better. Weil ich meine eigentlich ist das Ding geil. Ich habe jetzt diesen McPro seit Anfang des Jahres und ich will gar nicht davon weg.
Gebrauchtkopf?
Ja, ist ein 2009er auch. Der ist jetzt irgendwie bis zum Anschlagfolge steckt mit allem was so geht und der ist leise, zuverlässig und vor allem man kann da irgendwie Grafikkarten reinstecken und so und eigentlich ist das cooler. Ich habe hier so drei Bildschirme dran und so. Ich meine, mach das mal mit dem iMac. Es geht immer alles nur so theoretisch irgendwann mal vielleicht unter Umständen. Ja, so und dann gibt es hier noch diese komische Gerüchtelage mit neuen MacBooks, wobei ich jetzt zwei so komische Specksheet-Leaks sehe. Nämlich einmal für den 13 Zoller und einmal für den 15 Zoller.
Beides MacBook Pros einfach nur?
Ja.
Also mit CD-ROM und allem?
Das ist ein bisschen verwirrend. Also...
Poste doch mal links.
Heise meint...
Was ist denn jetzt hier? Sag doch mal so.
Nein, To 5 Mac hat irgendwas mit einem 13 Zoller gepostet. Heise wiederum bezieht sich da zwar drauf, aber da ist irgendwas mit einem 15 Zoller. Deswegen bin ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen verwirrt. Und bei diesem 15 Zoller Ding steht halt das Teil habe. 15,4 Zoll Display?
Nein.
Doch.
I'm looking at it right now. Ich weiß, bei 9to5 gibt es noch ein anderes mit 13.
Ich glaube, ich würde dich verarschen.
Das waffelst du ja an, was ich auf meinem Bildschirm habe.
Es steht da.
2.560 x 1.600 Pixel.
Das ist groß, ne?
Das kann auch voll gefakt sein. Das ist so expectations.
Das kriegt doch niemand hin, so ein Zettel auszudrucken und dann abzufotografieren.
Seit wann hat Heise denn akkurate Romas am Start?
Na, es ist von 9to5 Mac.
Ja, aber die haben doch angeblich jetzt das ganz gut.
Wir glauben, dass es jetzt einfach erst mal so wie es hier ist.
Bis dann, 2.560 x 1.600 ist nicht anders als bei so Retina-esque, oder?
Aber geht das denn überhaupt auf? Müsste das nicht?
Das ist das Doppelte von dem von 1280 x 800.
Aber das wäre dann 13 Zoll, oder?
Das wäre das Doppelte von 13 Zoll.
Kann sein.
Das ist das, was hier steht.
Wir machen dich jetzt auch nicht persönlich dafür ver- Also, natürlich ein bisschen schon, aber.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher. Ja, es gibt auf diesem anderen 13 Zoll-Ding, da steht ja sogar auch noch was von Superdrive drauf.
Naja, es ist halt das Pro, nicht das R.
Aber warte, das 15er hat kein Superdrive und das 13er schon.
Ja, das ist unklar. Ich meine, hier steht auch Firewire 800-Port und USB 3.0-Ports. Also ich glaube nicht, dass hier von einem R die Rede ist. Auch Gigabit Ethernet sei dabei und 2,1,3 Kilo. 2,1,3 Kilo, wo es derzeit so bei 2,56 oder so was ist.
Das liest sich doch eigentlich mehr wie ein 15 Zoll R.
Nein, das liest sich nicht wie ein 15 Zoll R, sondern das liest sich wie ein Pro, weil da ist nämlich Ethernet und Firewire drin.
Naja, vielleicht hat das Pro jetzt einfach dann kein Superdrive mehr und wie es endlich mal Zeit wird.
Naja, das sagen wir ja hier schon seit zwei Jahren, dass das genauso kommt. Dass es eine 15 Zoll-Variante gibt, ohne Laufwerk.
Ja, jetzt ist er da!
Die aber ein bisschen, also entweder noch ein bisschen dicker ist oder das reicht allein hier tiefer zu sein und dann Platz zu haben für einen Ethernet-Port. Tja, das wär schon ein cooles Gerät, aber ich weiß nicht, das kann auch einfach nur so Wunschdenken sein und wir machen ja mal ein bisschen Photoshop und so. Was meint der Chat?
Knapp 100-200 PPI.
Der Chat meint, es gibt einen Apple Store in Köln. Ja, der macht doch bestimmt noch auf, bevor der in Berlin nur ansatzweise am Start ist.
Und, was meint er, kommt ein neues iPhone?
Nicht zur WWDC.
Meint er, das war jetzt so der neue Rhythmus.
Haben wir nicht letztes Mal schon über dieses lange iPhone-Ding geredet? Haben wir schon, ne?
Aber da waren noch keine, da waren noch nicht die Rückseppdrückteile aufgetaucht.
Da haben wir lange über das lange iPhone geredet. Aber es ist ja das lange iPhone-Display, das iPhone selbst ist ja gleich lang.
Nee, das war auch noch so ein Hauch länger. Aber nur so ein Hauch, also jetzt nichts, was einen groß grämen dürfte. Das Hauptsache ist, es ist gleich breit. Das ist entscheidender.
Ich bin ja langsam an dem Punkt, wo ich glaube, das ist es.
Da bin ich auch.
Also das ist...
Das macht so Sinn, das ist so sinnvoll. Ich hab da am Anfang auch ein bisschen in die Nase gerumpft, da dachten wir so, hm, aber wenn sie jetzt nach fünf Jahren da mal den... Das hätte ich fast vorm Faktor gesagt, die Display Aspekt Ratio ändern, also wenn sie das Layout überhaupt mal anfassen, dann ist so der Schritt auf 16 zu 9. Aber die Beibehaltung der Breite für die Benutzbarkeit und auch die Verlängerung des Bildschirms macht dahingehend Sinn, als dass es eben so wie das iPhone ja im User-Interface gemacht ist, schon sehr Porträt orientiert ist. Das merkt man ja auch schon in diesem Locking-Modus, es gibt kein Locking für Landscape, aber es gibt ein Locking für Porträt. Das heißt, dass sie dem schon immer Priorität eingeräumt haben, weil so hast du es halt normalerweise in der Kralle. Auch wenn ich trotzdem gerne ein Locking für Landscape hätte.
Vielleicht, also ich meine, Samsung hat ja bei diesem Galaxy S3, haben sie einen ganz hübschen Modus eingebaut, der automatisch erkennt, wenn Augen auf das Display gucken und dann nicht in den Sleep-Modus geht. Also das Display geht nicht in den Sleep-Modus, solange jemand draufguckt, was ich eine schöne Sache finde. Und das könnte man natürlich auch geil nutzen, dass man einfach nicht...
Dein Telefon schaut dich die ganze Zeit an? Wir haben die ganze Zeit die Kamera eingeschaltet?
Nee, nee, nur alle Minute mal, wenn das ausgehen würde, guckts. Ist noch einer da? Und wenn du noch da bist, gehts nicht aus. Ansonsten gehts aus. Das gibt es auch jetzt auch schon in Laptops, glaube ich. Habe ich die Meinung?
Aber wenn sie in der Lage sind, Augen zu erkennen, dann wissen sie auch, wie rum die Augen gerade gucken.
Aber dafür haben sie auch die ganzen...
Wie rum die Augen gucken?
Na ja, du sitzt... Da können sie nachgucken, wie du vor dem iPhone davor sitzt. Das heißt, sie könnte, oder vor dem entsprechenden Telefon... Das heißt, sie könnten ein Telefon bauen, wo du auf der Seite liegen kannst, und trotzdem das Display in dem richtigen Modus ist. Mensch, Tim!
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich...
Das war doch nach Serien...
Genau, Ziel!
Und dass man dann quasi daran, dass endlich dein Modus kommt, dass du unter der Bettdecke heimlich Filme im Querformat gucken kannst.
Aber nur heimlich.
Tja, ich glaube, das kommt.
Aber nicht zu WWDC.
Ich bin da noch nicht ganz... Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schön finde, dieses 16 zu 9 Display. Ich finde es nach wie vor nicht so eine tolle Idee, aber ich glaube, dass das Gehäuse ist.
Warum findest du das keine tolle Idee?
Ich mag 4 zu 3 bei so kleinen Geräten, finde ich irgendwie angenehm. 4 zu 3 oder 3 zu 2. Ich finde, das ist so dieses kleinere Format. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben sie ja irgendwas ganz Tolles ausgedacht. Also ich glaube auf keinen Fall, glaube ich, an diese ganzen Gerüchte, die kommen, dass da so ein ständiges Doc unten sei, so ein App-Switcher-Doc, das glaube ich keine Sekunde lang. Das hat sich ja irgendwie jemand ausgedacht. Also quasi diese Doc-Leiste dann unten, die man, wenn man jetzt zweimal den Homebutton drückt, dass die dann dauerhaft eingeblendet ist. Das machen die auf keinen Fall, sondern es wird auch kein Notification Area werden oder so was. Nein. Das wird ein Bereich sein, den die Apps voll zur Verfügung haben. Was ich mir eventuell vorstellen könnte, dass wenn sie schon mal dich dazu zwingen, also eigentlich bist du ja jetzt schon gezwungen nach oben, relativ flexibel zu sein, was die Größe angeht, weil ja oben die Status-Leiste breiter werden kann und die Tastatur unterschiedlich hoch und so was, dass sie das dann eben nutzen, um das so umzubauen, wie das WebOS hatte. WebOS hatte ja ein ganz schönes Notification-System, dass die dann unten so drinnen kleben bleiben und dass dann so zum Beispiel so ein Player, so ein Musikplayer auch eben immer den aktuellen Titel da rund einblenden konnte und Play-Pause-Buttons und so was einblenden konnte.
Ah, der Recht.
Und dass sie das vielleicht irgendwie nutzen, um jetzt zu sagen, ok, wenn wir es schon nach oben hin anpassbar machen in der Höhe, den ganzen Scheiß, wenn die sowieso einmal ran müssen, dann können wir ja das da flexibel halten. Ja, aber eben wirklich so flexibel, dass du, also im Augenblick, es gibt so viele Apps, die können damit überhaupt nicht umgehen, wenn da plötzlich die Status-Leiste...
Ja, weil sie immer so ein bisschen drauf geschissen haben, aber wenn so ein neues Telefon rauskommt, dann kannst du dir vorstellen, wie schnell die Updates da reinregenen.
Und wenn du dann gleich sagst, ok, stell dich drauf ein, dass es manchmal eben noch unten noch ein bisschen kleiner ist, beziehungsweise variable, dann tut das auch nicht mehr weh. Also, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Aber nicht zur WWDC.
Nicht zur WWDC wahrscheinlich.
Aber vielleicht machen sie Sessions, wo sie sagen, ihr könnt euch schon mal drauf einstellen.
Nee, das machen sie nicht.
Das machen sie nicht.
Haben wir denn sonst noch irgendwelche Prädiktionen?
Für die WWDC.
Wie sind denn so eure Erwartungen? Warst du schon mal, Robb?
Ich war letztes Jahr schon mal.
Und?
Der letzte Steve Jobs Live-Auftritt.
Und wie war das so?
Ist gut. Das heißt nicht umsonst die Worldwide Drinking Competition. Also das ganze Geld, was man in Apple Hardware investiert über das Jahr, kann man dann mit Apple Mitarbeitern wieder der Leber zu Gute führen.
Wieso? Gibt es das kostenlos?
Wenn man da jemanden kennt, dann können die einen schon mal einladen. Das geht schon mal.
Das heißt, du hast da mal so ein komplettes Begruch Pro durchgesoffen, oder was?
Das haben meine Kollegen teilweise nicht ganz mitmachen können. Die sind ja auch ein bisschen älter als ich. Und dann bin ich immer gespannt, wie lange Max ausreicht.
Das wird schwer.
Also ich werde jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber...
Gibt ja so Drinking Games.
In der Keynote dann.
Immer, wenn Tim Cook sagt...
Amazing.
Dann gleich...
Es gab doch letztes Jahr, stand doch auf den Bändchen drauf, auf den Bierbändchen, if found, bring back to the WWDC, Bring back to the Moscone Center, glaube ich.
Ja, ich erinnere mich nicht mehr genau, was da drauf stand.
Das deutet darauf hin, dass das Bändchen gut funktioniert hat. Also auf jeden Fall waren da deutliche Hinweise drauf, wenn ihr irgendwo betrunkener Ecke gefunden habt, springen bitte wieder zurück. Mach mal Robb schreien oder?
So besser?
Weil sich ein paar Leute beschweren, dass er zu leise sei.
Robb muss ja lauter reden.
Ja, aber doch nicht voll mit Hick.
Test, 1, 2.
Das ist immer noch einen halben Kilometer von seinem Gesicht entfernt, aber...
Was?
Genau.
Jetzt noch was.
Noch was?
Also ich erwarte, ja, was war schon gesagt, Maps und hoffentlich geile neue MacBooks.
Und Mountain Lion kommt natürlich auch mal.
Ja, ach, die Mountain Lion.
Dafür könnten die Labs auch sein, dass da irgendwas kommt, was wir nicht erwarten.
Bleib mir weg mit Mountain.
Facebook-Integration?
Die könnten so viele tolle Sachen machen. Haben wir doch hier schon tausendmal Haufen runter gebeten. Ich hab auch keine Lust, mich tausendmal zu bewerben. Wieso nicht? Ja, ich hab Lust, aber heute nicht. Ich bin halt, wie wir es jetzt ja auch schon in den letzten Sendungen gesagt haben, so ein bisschen ernüchtert. Und ich denk mir so, okay, ich geh jetzt einfach mit Nullerwartung an die Sache ran, damit ich wenigstens noch so ein bisschen geflasht werde. Aber es gibt ja auch kaum Rumors. Selbst jetzt hier diese Notebook-Specifications ist ja eher so...
Ja, halt neues Notebook, ja.
Also, ein neues iPhone gibt's, den Formfaktor.
Ja, aber niemand behauptet wirklich ernsthaft, dass das iPhone so wie WWDC vorgestellt wird. Und das wird auch nicht stattfinden.
Aber hier, Maps ist auf jeden Fall ein Rumor, der jetzt mittlerweile relativ sicher sein dürfte.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch... Also, super exciting ist halt auch anders, ne?
Und es gab ja kurze Gerüchte über ein neues User-Interface.
Bleibt noch diese Apple TV-Geschichte. Du hast ja vorhin angesprochen, Robb, was könntest du dir denn vorstellen?
Naja, es gab ja vor nicht allzu lange Zeit das neue Update, das neue Firmware-Update, wo auch ein neues Interface mit eingeführt wurde, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Und das geht ja schon so ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung App-Icons auf dem Start-Bildschirm. Ich selber hab kein Apple TV, ich seh das immer nur auf Arbeit. Und ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich nur eine Frage der Zeit. Und letztes Jahr gab's Airplay, das war ja schon so ein Schritt in die Richtung. Jetzt kannst du deine Rennspiele halt auf dem Fernseher angucken und mit dem iPad lenken.
Ja gut, aber was ist das User-Interface dafür? Diese Fernbedienung?
Ich fürchte es fast.
Ja, aber was soll dann sozusagen, also was... Was kommt dann da? Also das Einzige, was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass sie eigentlich genau dasselbe tun, was sie auch derzeit auf dem iPhone machen. Dass sie sowas ermöglichen, wie ein Fernsehkanal macht seine eigene ab, der quasi der Vrepper ist für ihren Fernsehkanal. Der aber mehr bringt als nur das Fernsehen, sondern der eben auch sonstige interaktive Elemente mit drin hat, wie eben diese Basketballgeschichte, wo du quasi deinen eigenen Guide mit drin hast, was gerade läuft und so weiter. Dass so jeder Kanal eben auch genau das wird, nämlich so seine eigene Welt, seine eigene Abhaltung.
Wie ist denn das bei diesem Basketball-Kanal? Kann man das dann nur auf dem Fernseher sehen? Oder kann man sich die Statistiken dazu auch auf dem iPad angucken?
Das hat erstmal mit dem iPad gar nichts zu tun, das Apple TV. Also es gibt die App auch fürs iPad. Und du kannst natürlich vom iPad auch auf den großen Bildschirm streamen. Du brauchst halt noch nicht mal ein iPad, um es auf dem großen Bildschirm zu sehen. Und das sind quasi ja schon Apps. Es ist die Frage, wer die geschrieben hat. Ob Apple die geschrieben hat? Die, die geschrieben haben, die machen ja ganz gute Apps. Also sie schreiben ja auch vermutlich ihre eigene App auf dem iPad. Also könnten sie im Prinzip auch die ganze Zeit mit Apple... Also meine Vermutung ist, die stecken halt unter einer Decke. Steve Jobs kann die irgendwie gut leiden, oder die konnten ihn gut leiden, oder was auch immer. Und der hat ihnen das irgendwie verkauft und die haben das halt begriffen, dass das einfach ein sehr geiler Zugang ist zu ihrem Content. Der ja hochspezifisch ist, wo es eine große Nachfrage gibt, Sport geht immer, Live-Bedarf, Wiederholungsbedarf, Statistiken, dieser ganze Bim-Bim, etc. Und vor allem, du kannst den Leuten halt Subscriptions verkaufen. Jede App ist im Prinzip auch nochmal ihr eigener Subscription-Kanal. Es sei denn, sie verkaufen das eben in irgendeinem Bundle auch noch. Und ich denke, also das ist immer meine Vermutung gewesen, was Apple eigentlich möchte. Also diese Vision, Apple macht Fernsehen. Unabhängig davon, ob sie jetzt auch einen Fernseher bauen. Wichtiger ist vielmehr, wie bedient es sich und was kriegst du dann? Und sie würden sofort, wenn alle Ja sagen würden, diese ganzen Fernsehsender quasi als Up damit draufnehmen. Also nicht mehr so dieses alte 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, sondern du hast dann halt irgendwie Ups und dann denken sie sich vielleicht noch irgendwas Schlaues mit Shortcuts oder so aus, womit du das mappen kannst, keine Ahnung. Aber der ganze Content kommt übers Netz. Ausschließlich kein Kabel, kein Satellit, kein Scheiß, sondern einfach Voraussetzung ist Breitband, Internet. Das gibt es natürlich nicht überall, aber Apple setzt das Problem einfach aus, weil in drei Jahren sind wir schon wieder weiter und die Situation wird halt immer besser. Und über kurz oder lang wirst du, dadurch, dass du dann auch per Satellit irgendwo Internet hinbringst, halt auch das Fernsehen da hinbringen. Und die Leute wollen sowieso nicht 270 Kanäle, sondern die gucken halt das, das, das oder das. Und wenn du dir dann nur das runterlädst und nur das einkaufst, was dich wirklich interessiert, von Apple, so wie du es derzeit eben als Pauschalpaket von einem Satellitenbetreiber bekommst oder einem Kabelbetreiber, der dir halt so ein Paket macht und der sich von den Fernsehsendern dafür bezahlen lässt, dass die Sender da überhaupt drauf sind. Das Business will Apple halt gerne so übernehmen. Allein schon, weil sie es eben auch kuratieren wollen. Apple-Style. Da kommt dann nicht jeder drauf. Und dann gibt es da auch keine Pornokanäle und lalala. So das übliche Spiel. Und sie bemühen sich, dass das eben auch alles hochinteraktiv ist. Dann gibt es natürlich den Disney Channel, wo du dann eben auch sofort auf das ganze Archiv zugreifen kannst und die ganzen Serien angucken. Du brauchst dann auch keinen Videorekorder mehr, weil das irgendwie alles eine Wolke ist. Dieser iTunes-Store wird quasi zum Fernsehen und wird dadurch noch ergänzt durch Live-Programm, was eben auch noch dabei sein muss. Wobei ich glaube, da muss man dann nochmal 30 Sekunden später jubeln, wenn EM ist.
Also ich glaube, ich sag jetzt einfach mal, es wird ein bisschen anders kommen, als du sagst. Als meine Prediction sozusagen. Und zwar ist jetzt meine Vermutung eher, dass die gehen das ganze Ding total vom iPad her an. Also es gibt die Fernbedienung, die man dabei hat bei dem Ding, die wird zum Einschalten. Und so für die notwendigste Bedienung wird die da sein. In erster Linie hast du dein iPad. Diese Airplay-Integration von dem Apple TV, die ist einfach geil. Ich finde das teilweise wirklich angenehm. So abends, ich lieg auf der Couch rum, surfe ein bisschen im Netz rum, da ist ein spannendes Video, will ich mir angucken, kann ich jetzt auf dem iPad angucken. Und wenn der Fernseher eh gerade läuft, dann schalte ich einfach, drücke ich da dieses Airplay-Icon und dann spielt er das halt auf dem Fernseher an, dann kann ich mir das da angucken. Meine Freundin, die guckt mittlerweile ihre Lieblingsserien. Also die ist großer Fan von Germany's Next Topmodel, hatten wir ja schon mal. Da gibt's von Pro7 eine entsprechende App. Funktioniert auch ganz okay, lädt sie aufs iPad runter, startest, machst einen Airplay-Modus an. Ist leider von der Auflösung her eine ziemliche Katastrophe. Und sie haben es nicht geschafft, dass ich es echt peinlich finde, den Auto-Locking-Mode abzuschalten, während das Video läuft, sodass nach einer gewissen Zeit das iPad sich halt einfach ausgeht und damit dein Videostream abbricht, was darauf hinläutet, wie lange die es bei Pro7 getestet haben im Alltag.
Großes Kino sag ich dazu.
Sie muss dann immer dieses Locking abschalten, aber dann funktioniert das wirklich ganz hervorragend. Und es funktioniert einfach, du startest die App auf deinem iPad, es könnte bequemer nicht sein. Du hast hier nicht irgendwie mit Fernbedienung und Tasten drücken und alles kompliziert. Und wenn es dann soweit ist, nehmen wir mal an, das würden sie jetzt besser integrieren mit dem iPad. Zum Beispiel könnte man ja auch sagen, wenn du dir auf dem iPad eine bestimmte App runterlädst, dann erscheint eben auch auf deinem Apple TV das entsprechende Icon. Und du kannst das Setup und was der Teufel war, und lätst dir deine ganzen Filme, und so suchst du dir übers iPad aus. Aber die Steuerung geht dann auch über ein Apple TV. Wenn sowas kommen würde, das würde ich extrem geil finden.
Also ich kann mir das sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie da eine maximale Integration mit dem iPad anstreben. Ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, dass der ganze Spaß auch ohne iPad funktionieren muss.
Wozu? Im Augenblick funktioniert es eigentlich auch nicht wirklich ohne das iPad.
Weil das einfach TV ist. TV ist, du legst dich zurück mit einem dicken Bauch in deinen Sofa, und du hast da irgendwie so ein kleines Nippelchen, das du dir nicht angucken musst in der Hand. Und rülpsen, schipsfressend irgendwie. Da hast du irgendwie an und dann muss da was laufen. Es muss auch so eine Instant-Gratification sein und nicht wisch wisch wisch wisch wisch. In welchem Ordner war denn das?
Siri-Steuerung.
Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte ist, dieser Weg scheint extrem steinig zu sein, weil sie wollen halt alle nicht, weil sie jetzt alle Schiss haben vor Apple. Was mit der Musik damals noch geklappt hat, ist jetzt wollen sie einfach alle nicht. Und die Frage für mich ist halt, wie schaffen sie es, dieses Kartell da zu durchbrechen, das sie nicht mitspielen lassen will? Alle sind gegen sie. Die Kabelprovider, die Satellitenbetreiber, Hollywood, alle wollen sich ihre vermeintliche Macht nicht nehmen lassen, weil auch alle auf gleichem Maße Angst haben müssen. Mittlerweile sind wir so, Apple kann mittlerweile jeder Firma massiv Konkurrenz machen, der also in irgendeiner Form im Technologiefeld spielt. Jeder. Und einschließlich der ganzen Medien jetzt auch. Bis hin zu Zeitungen und so weiter. Alle zittern. Zurecht auch. Und die wollen also jetzt nicht. Also was ist jetzt der Plan von Apple, damit sie irgendwie alle einen Arsch hochkriegen? Eigentlich können sie halt nur sehr geschickt alle gegeneinander ausspielen.
Müssen sie dafür überhaupt so viel machen? Ich meine, die sind doch...
Sie brauchen den Content.
Ja, aber auf dem iPad sind die meisten doch schon.
Die meisten ist da irgendwie... Wo ist da ZDF, ARD?
ZDF Mediathek, gibt es eine offizielle App?
Ja Mediathek. Ich rede von Fernsehen.
Das ist doch Fernsehen.
Ich rede von dem, was live...
Das passiert nicht. Das wird beim Apple TV nicht passieren.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Man wird Sportereignisse live sehen können. Da machen sie dann halt mit der UEFA oder mit wem auch immer machen sie ihre Verträge.
Warum sollte das nicht kommen?
Weil das durch ist.
Wer guckt denn live?
Fußballfans.
Ja, sag ich ja. Sportereignisse.
Ja, was ist, wenn Apple sich die WM kauft? Die Kohle haben sie. Locker. Schau dir an, was dafür bezahlt wird.
Da brauchen sie keinen Fernsehsender.
Apple geht da hin und sagt Fußball-WM, nächstes Jahr Brasilien, kaufen wir. Komplett. Ja, für welches Land denn, Herr Cook? Ja, alle. Aber das ist teuer.
Egal.
Ja, hier ist mein Experte. Reden Sie mit dem. Tschüss, danke.
Das war's.
Ja, aber dafür brauchen sie keinen Fernsehsender. Da machst du ein paar Sportereignisse, gehst direkt zu den entsprechenden Verwerter. Denen ist das scheißegal.
Ja, aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die Leute hier nur Fernsehen im Sport gucken. Die wollen auch NBC gucken, die wollen auch irgendwie John Stewart gucken.
Das kann man asynchron gucken.
Das kann man asynchron gucken. Aber man darf nicht unterschätzen, wie wichtig im Fernsehen immer noch live ist. Live heißt, das läuft zu einer bestimmten Uhrzeit und du kannst davon ausgehen, dass alle deine Freunde das dann auch schon gesehen haben danach. Man guckt dir doch mal diesen Tatort-Twitter-Zwang an. Wie sie sich alle um 20.15 Uhr da vor ihrer Tastatur klar machen und so weiter. Und stell dir mal vor, der eine würde Tatort eine halbe Stunde später gucken. Ich meine, das funktioniert einfach nicht mehr.
Das würde tausendmal besser funktionieren.
Nee, das würde nicht, weil dann alle sich gegenseitig spoilern würden die ganze Zeit. Dann kannst du ja gar nicht mehr mitreden. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Stell dir mal vor, ich würde die WM zehn Minuten vor allen anderen ziehen.
Nein, wie gesagt, Sportereignisse sind eine andere Nummer. Aber so was wie...
Tatort auch?
Tatort, also ich meine Tatort, das ist wirklich so ein Thema, damit kannste dich wirklich gar nicht locken.
Du weißt, dass das populär ist. Wir sind ja auch live.
Nennt noch mal ein paar Zeilen. Wie viele Leute...
Ihr hört es ja zehn Minuten früher als wir.
Oh, heute sind es noch mal... Achso, nee, ist jetzt hier... Oh Gott, wie viele sind das denn? Mit 400?
Ach, jetzt verstehe ich das erst.
300, 50, 60, sowas. Ich kann es ja auch hier genau sagen. Früher war das besser. 429. Ja, ist nicht so gut aufgelöst. Ich dachte, das wäre cool mit logarithmisch. Also es ist gut zum Testen, aber es ist schlecht für große Zahlen.
Und wie viele hören live? Und wie viele hören asynchron?
Das hören auf jeden Fall noch sehr viel mehr Leute später. Das ist ja auch nicht die Frage. Weißte Geier, bloß es gibt... Ich sag einfach nur, unterschätzt nicht, wie groß auch ein Live-Bedarf ist. Kann sein, dass das nicht ihr Hauptding ist. Aber wenn sie nicht alle Filme kriegen und wenn sie nicht auch die wichtigen Sender und deren Programme haben, da musst du halt auch Daily Show gucken können. Da musst du auch irgendwie die wichtigen Talksendungen schauen können. Wenn man das jetzt mal nur auf Deutschland beziehen würde, da willst du dann halt auch Montag früh dieses bekloppte Politikergekeife dann auch gesehen haben, damit du dann dich mit deinen Arbeitskollegen darüber streiten kannst.
Aber das kannst du auch über diese ZDF Mediathek App zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber wenn das am Sonntagabend läuft und danach kriegen die Leute ins Bett und morgen wollen sie schon wieder drüber reden.
Also ich bin ja zum Beispiel Game of Thrones. Ich guck das nie.
Das ist ein anderer Content.
Das ist ein Fernsehen.
Nee, das ist Serien. Das ist mehr so Hollywood. Der Tatort ist aber auch wirklich ein gemeinsames Rätselraten. Das ist so wer ist der Mörder? Wer ist diese Woche der Mörder? Und auf Twitter steht es dann auch, wenn die Sendung fertig ist.
Also das muss ich tatsächlich sagen, so diesen ganzen Tatort-Hype auf Twitter, den kann ich überhaupt nicht verstehen. Das mag sein, dass das so eine gewisse Live-Komponente hat. Aber das funktioniert doch. Warum müsste Apple das integrieren? Wozu? Das ist eine funktionierende Sache.
Wenn wir von Apple TV im Sinne von Apple geht in den Fernsehmarkt reden, dann können wir das nicht komplett ohne Fernsehen machen.
Bei Live-Fernsehen können doch die Leute mit einer App machen. Da ist ja auch das ganze Realtime-Streaming ein Kostenfaktor.
Aber diese App muss ja auch den Content kriegen. Und wenn den Apple keiner geben will, ich meine, du musst ja auch eine Infrastruktur machen.
Wenn ProSieben da gerne seine TV-Total-Events gerne live streamen möchte, dann müssen sie halt eine passende App da reinstellen.
Ja, aber vielleicht wollen sie das ja gar nicht. Vielleicht wollen sie ja sagen, nein, Apple kriegt nicht 30% von unseren Werbeeinnahmen.
Dann guckt wahrscheinlich keiner mehr ProSieben. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich das in Angst machen müssen.
Du meinst, die Leute gucken künftig nur noch das, was auf Apple TV ist?
Oder sie gucken uns asynchron bei YouTube.
Nein, wenn das weiterhin diese kleine Standalone Box bleibt, diese kleine Apple TV, diese kleine schwarze Kasten, dann ist das überhaupt kein Problem. Warum muss da auch noch irgendwie Live-Fernsehen rauskommen? Du hast da irgendwie deine Kabelbox daneben stehen oder deine DVB-S oder DVB-T oder so, kommt alles überall mehr oder weniger gutes HD-Fernsehen raus. Das finde ich ein weitgehend gelöstes Problem. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Apple daran großes Interesse hätte.
Apple will die Nummer eins sein auf diesem Gerät. Apple will der Ort sein, über den du deinen Content auswählst.
Ja, genau. Und das ist halt, wenn du dieses Live-Fernsehen haben willst, dann guck doch deinen Live-Fernsehen. Und wenn du das andere haben willst, wenn du das bessere haben willst, wenn du es nämlich dann haben willst, wenn du es hast, wenn du darüber auch dein eigenes haben willst, wenn du darüber einen Facetime machen willst, wenn du darüber, weißt ja Teufel was, dann nimmst du den Apple TV.
Ja, aber die Leute schnallen nicht zwei Ports umschalten zwischen, dass es nervt. Das ist einfach eine Experience.
Das müssen sie jetzt auch schon machen.
Ja, jetzt müssen sie es machen und alle nervt es. So, und in dem Moment, wo du erstmal in einer Welt bist, wo du das nicht tun musst, weil du alles irgendwie über Ups machst.
Aber, also ich meine, wenn sie das geschnallt haben, dann schnallen sie auch, dass Asynchron besser ist als hier alle gleichzeitig.
Asynchron ist nicht immer besser.
Es gibt wenige Ausnahmefälle, es gibt ganz wenige Ausnahmefälle, aber es gibt da wirklich nicht viel. Naja, es gibt Sport.
Ja, Sport, hatten wir jetzt schon hundertmal. Ja, aber das ist das, was die Menschen da draußen machen.
Ja, sollen sie, sollen sie. Nein, das machen sie nicht den ganzen Tag, aber haben wir doch darüber geredet. Aber darüber hinaus, ob da jetzt NBC dabei ist oder ARD live dabei ist, wir kommen da nicht weiter.
Also die Frage ist, gibt es was Neues auf der WWDC zu dem Thema? Du sagst, es kommen Ups.
Genau.
Und die Ups sind wie?
Wie gesagt, iPad ist entweder iPhone oder iPad ist integraler Bestandteil, also der Apple TV wird zu einer Erweiterung von den bestehenden iOS-Geräten. Ohne das Ding bist du eigentlich wie jetzt auch schon. Das ist ja am Augenblick auch schon keine echte...
Du bist du der Meinung, dass man nach der WWDC Ups machen kann, die auf diesem Apple TV selbst laufen?
Die nativ da direkt auf dem Gerät laufen? Ja, aber es wird keinen App Store auf dem Gerät geben. Das sind Companionsachen fürs iPad. Du lädst dir dein iPad-App runter?
Das gibt's doch schon.
Naja, aber eben, dass du mehr Steuerung auch über das Gerät selber, also dass du dann auch das iPad zur Seite legen kannst und dann wirklich die komplette Steuerung auch über die Fernbedienung machen kannst. Du kannst das Video steuern, aber du kannst nicht zum Beispiel Navigationen da auf dem Fernseher aufbauen oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, aber womit willst du es dann machen? Willst du dir die Touch-Bedienung mit dieser normalen Family?
Das ist die Zweite-User-Festbau. In erster Linie machst du das über das iPad. Also du holst das iPad raus und touchst da drauf rum. Oder du hast so eine Minimal-Bedienung, die ist dann auch über die Fernbedienung.
Also wenn es schon so lange dauert mir das zu erklären, dann wirst du das bestimmt den geblendeten Massen nicht so schnell näher bringen können. Ich verstehe nicht so ganz genau, wo jetzt der Unterschied ist zu der Ist-Situation. Also was ist anders als jetzt?
Erstens, Companion-Apps, die auf dem Apple TV drauf sind. Du gehst auf den Apple TV, sagst da App starten, dann startet da die App.
Und dann?
Dann startet da die App.
Was ist das zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel Netflix gibt es jetzt schon, zum Beispiel ZDF Mediathek, zum Beispiel ProSieben, irgendwas. So.
Und dann?
Wie benutze ich die?
Die benutzt du auf zwei Arten. Entweder über die Fernbedienung, das wird eine minimale eingeschränkte Bedienung sein, mit der du nur das Allerwichtigste machen kannst.
Also wie jetzt mit dem Baseball-Kram? Du redest von dem Ist-Zustand.
Nein! Du kannst im Augenblick keine Apps auf dem Apple TV. Sind nicht drauf. Doch. Nein, sind nicht. Doch.
Da ist diese Baseball-App drauf.
Gut, dann hab ich's verpasst, dann hab ich das Apple TV SDK offensichtlich verpasst.
Nein, klar, das kann sein, dass auch andere Leute das jetzt machen können. Aber du redest im Prinzip von der selben Bedienungsgeschichte.
Nein, red ich nicht.
Wie jetzt auch.
Ich rede von einer starken Integration zwischen iOS-Gerät und Apple TV. Das ist das, worauf ich die ganze Zeit sage. Das ist das, was ich glaube, weil alles andere macht keinen Sinn. Über diese Scheißfernbedienung, die ist hübsch und die ist alles, aber darüber will niemand wirklich ein komplexes Interface bedienen. Und ein Apple TV, ich sag's nochmal, macht eigentlich so wirklich ohne iPad und iPhone keinen Sinn. Zumindest ist der, also für mich ist der einzige Mehrwert, der da ist, ist darin, dass ich Airplane nutzen kann. Und ich glaube, so wird's verdammt vielen Leuten geben und dann ist das sowas wie so ein, bei eben, bei irgendeinem Motorola-Telefon ist irgendein HDMI-Kabel dabei für 80 Euro und da kaufst du eben deine Wireless-Box dazu für 100 Euro und die kann dann eben noch deutlich mehr. Und das ist, und ich würde sagen, das macht dann ohne iOS-Gerät einfach noch weniger Sinn als jetzt.
Montag sind wir alle schlau.
Wann ist der richtige Not?
Zehn Uhr da. Das ist einfach Discord-Zeit.
19 Uhr hier. Oder 20?
18 Uhr.
Ich guck mal in den Schedule. Scheiße, Tab zu gemacht.
Ich guck mal in den Schedule.
Schön mit Tab-Objects.
Um 9 oder um 10 geht's, ne?
Wer spricht? Weiß man auch nicht, ne?
Na, ich geh mal aus, dass der Tim spricht, oder?
Ja, letztes Mal hab ich auf die gesprochen.
Ist ja nicht das Gleiche.
Oh Gott, hier meint irgendjemand im Chat. Ich kauf doch kein iPad, um mein Apple TV zu bedienen. Nein. Du sollst...
Um 10.
Du hast ein iPad.
Fertig.
So, wann ist denn das? San Francisco, Vereinigte Staaten, Los Angeles. Was hattest du?
Zehn Uhr?
Ja, 19 Uhr ist es hier.
Zehn Uhr, na ich trage das als Zehn Uhr ein und dann läuft das bis 12 Uhr wahrscheinlich.
Vor 30.
11 Uhr 30. Okay, das heißt... Na toll, Apple.
Na toll.
Das guckt doch keiner. Das haben sie wahrscheinlich wieder nicht live übertragen, ne?
Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Na weil da Frankreich gegen England spielt.
Da ist EM.
Echt nächste Woche geht das schon los?
Das geht diese Woche schon los.
Was?
Darüber sollten wir uns mal lieber unterhalten hier.
Oh na komm.
Übermorgen. Ole ole. Freitag. Freitag ist Polen, Griechenland und danach Russland, Tschechien. Krass. Ja, wir könnten mal, ich meine, wenn Apple sowieso so uninteressant ist, können wir doch einfach die nächsten...
Du findest Apple, wir finden Apple gar nicht uninteressant. Du findest die ganze Zeit Apple uninteressant.
Das ist auf dem absteigenden Ast.
Fußball auch.
Nee, ich meine, wir könnten einfach Mobile EM machen. Und einfach über die EM berichten. Na, da gibt es auf jeden Fall mehr Neues.
Da gibt es exakt gar nichts Neues.
Ist das Stadion fertig geworden in der Ukraine?
Das weiß ich nicht. Die haben ja auch noch Zeit, zwei Tage, ne?
Karten sollen extrem billig sein. Irgendwie so ein Deutschlandspiel für 20 Euro oder 22 Euro oder sowas, die Tickets.
Will keiner hin.
Also noch mal kurz nach Kiew fliegen. Und Kiew ist eine schöne Stadt. Flüge kosten bestimmt nicht die Welt.
Fahrt doch mal rüber.
Ich guck mir das über DVB-T an.
So, ich hab...
Mit ITV.
Viel Glück.
So, ich will jetzt hier mal erzählen, was ich mir alles gekauft habe. Ich hab nämlich viele, viele Sachen gekauft.
Was hast du denn alles gekauft, Max?
Also WWDC ist jetzt der Deckel drauf. Okay, ich wollte nur fragen.
Ja, mach mal zu.
Ja, wollt ihr jetzt schon in die Produktgeschichte rein? Oder wollen wir uns nicht erst mal noch mal über...
Dauerwerbesendung?
Hast du noch wehrs?
Ich weiß nicht, also... Man könnte noch mal über diese Flatter-Geschichte reden. Das wäre ja meine Begeisterung.
Kann mir noch mal was Bier holen.
Ich hab dazu nicht so viel zu sagen, außer...
Außer? Mir egal.
Naja, also ich seh da nicht so schnell, also abseits von den Vorschlägen, die wir das letzte Mal hatten, seh ich ja nicht, dass da Apple sich so schnell irgendwie anders bewegen wird.
Na es gibt auf jeden Fall ein paar Wege, wie die Sache auf jeden Fall funktionieren kann. Und es gab mittlerweile ein Update von Flatter, also der App sozusagen. Und es gibt ja auch noch andere Apps, die Flatter API verwenden. Die haben aber eins gemeinsam, sie sind kostenlos. Und ich glaube, dass das auch so ein bisschen der Knackpunkt ist derzeit. Das haben wir glaube ich bei der Debatte letztes Mal so ein bisschen übersprungen. Dass es wahrscheinlich in dem Moment gar kein Problem ist, wo die App kostenlos ist.
Hat man glaube ich schon so ein bisschen auch besprochen.
Naja, was man ja jetzt machen könnte, erstens ist eine kostenlose App, die sozusagen Flatter hat. Und dann machst du halt den Rest irgendwie über In-App Purchases. Das wäre so die eine Variante. Also wenn jetzt jemand darüber nachdenkt, bitte.
Ja, aber ist ja schon so ein bisschen hintenrum. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie sich so etwas gefallen lassen. Gratis-App mit Flatter, die dann abgegradet wird über In-App Purchases.
Ja, für andere Funktionen, nicht für die Funktionalität. Es geht ja darum, dass diese eigentliche Funktionalität soll, also Spenden-Funktionalität soll nur, da soll die App kostenlos sein. Da steht aber nichts davon, dass eine andere Funktionalität nicht noch zugekauft werden darf. Das ist unklar, aber das kann sehr wohl sein und das müsste mal getestet werden. Zweite Sache ist, dass man natürlich in dem Moment, wo man sich den Luxus erlaubt, auch ein Backend zu haben, diese Flatter-Aktivität, also ist ja nicht nur so, dass du das Instacast zum Beispiel ein generisches Flatter-Feature hätte, sondern es ist ja gekoppelt an den eigentlichen normalen Programmablauf. Das heißt, du flatterst quasi dann, wenn du was hörst, also wenn du dieses Autoflatter angeschaltet hast. Und sprich, es geht hier eigentlich um deine Playlist, deine History, das was du halt gehört hast, das wird dann eben auch geflattert. Aber das könnte ja auch außerhalb der App geschehen. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo es ein Backend gibt, dem man das eben erzählen kann. Also wer jetzt sozusagen immer noch Interesse daran hat, so einen Medium Player zu machen mit der Integration, könnte er in dem Moment das eben in so einem Backend abwickeln. Was ja auch andere Vorteile erledigt, weil du willst ja auch Sinken über mehrere Geräte, das heißt, es schreit ohnehin so ein bisschen nach dem Account, auch wenn du es derzeit so einen expliziten Account nicht benötigst, wenn du iCloud verwendest. Aber sag mal, du willst auch noch andere Plattformen mit anbinden, also irgendwo macht das dann eben auch Sinn. Und dann könntest du eben auch entsprechende Settings anbieten auf dem Backend, wo du sagst, ok, alles wo ich jetzt hier irgendwie meinen Herzchenbutton gedrückt habe, mein Sternchen, so, mein Favorite, oder einfach alles, was ich gehört habe, meine History von gehörten Sachen, das liegt ja da ohnehin vor, und das dann bitte auch mal automatisch durchflettern. Dann hättest du diese Funktionalität wieder, aber es wäre nicht in der App. Und ich glaub nicht, dass Apple da ewig hinterherrennen kann und sagen kann, hier über fünf Ecken und so weiter, tut ihr irgendwo was falsch. Das ist ja auch nicht ihr Konzern an der Stelle.
Das klingt überzeugend.
Ich glaube nämlich auch nicht unbedingt, ich ausschließen will ich das auch auf gar keinen Fall, dass das jetzt wieder so eine ausgeprägte Evilness ist, die sich an der Stelle so breit nach dem Motto oh, bezahlt, sonst weiter, geh weg. Sondern da geht es halt mit dieser Charity-Regelung ja sozusagen auch um das Verhindern von Fraud. Da steckt ja auch so ein bisschen was dahinter. Hier Spenden und so, wenn da gespendet wird, dann darf dafür eben nicht auch noch Geld genommen werden. Und an der Stelle greift dann wahrscheinlich auch diese Regel eben für ihr Weltbild auch für Flatter. Das ist natürlich immer noch bekloppt für alle Programme, die sich jetzt kein Backend leisten können oder wollen, oder wo das einfach konzeptionell keinen Sinn macht für den speziellen Bereich von Podcast-Apps. Denke ich mal, könnte man da eben schon was machen. Am Ende müsste man eben so einen generischen Service anbieten. Ist man so ein, keine Ahnung, hier sowas wie... Hier ist nochmal dieses Twitter-Ding, Tweet-Marker, der sich so merkt, wo du in deiner Timeline zuletzt warst. Das ist ja auch so mehr so eine zentrale Gedankenstütze. Genauso könnte man ja auch so einen Podmarker-Dienst machen, wo so jeder Client mit so zwei, drei Calls sagen kann, so hallo hier, ich bin Client XY, hab den User-Account. Hier ist eine Episode, die ich gehört habe. Hier ist irgendwie ein Favorite, so leg mal ab, so. Und dann flatter das mal für mich. Und dann hätte man das sozusagen auch noch gleich als Dienstleistung und würde eben diesen Aufwand dann nicht selber programmieren müssen. Keine Ahnung, ist nur so eine Idee.
Könnte man vielleicht sogar mit Facebook hacken. Dass du es einfach in die Graph-API tust. Tim hat das gehört und dann geht hintenrum, flatter, in deinen Facebook-Account guckt, na was hat denn der Tim also gehört? Und dann Auto-flatter.
Du meinst so eine Facebook-Up?
Facebook hat hier eine generische Personen-Verb-Objekt-API mit der Graph-API.
Die finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, die Idee.
Wie würde das funktionieren?
Na du connectest deinen Instacast mit Facebook. Weil du alles automatisch sharen möchtest, was du hörst. Macht ja auch Sinn.
Das müsste ich dann auch tun.
Na so wie Spotify das macht oder so.
Genau, das machen ja genug Leute. Soundcloud macht das ja auch. Kannst du einstellen, Autoshare.
Ich will doch nicht alles ins Facebook reinschreiben, was ich höre.
Ist doch Post-Privacy hier, dachte ich.
Nein, Tim ist nicht da, hier ist nicht Post-Privacy.
Privacy ist an der Stelle gar nicht der Punkt. Ich will doch die Leute in die nerven.
Also das ist doch eh nur recht im Newsticker. Das geht ja nicht in deine Timeline.
Das ist doch egal, wo das ist. Ich hab das in meiner Timeline hier, ich zeig dir.
Echt?
Ich seh da auch noch irgendwelche Leute, die ihre komischen Playlists auf Spotify sind, in meiner Timeline.
Aber dann sharen die die vielleicht extra.
Warte mal, wie hat sich heute hier in der Timeline schon gesehen?
Ich hab jetzt Facebook schon seit 2,5 Jahren nicht mehr offen gehabt.
Listen to the Playlist on Last FM und Spotify. Und dann hab ich das hier mittendrin.
Achso, aber es ist aggregiert, oder?
Falls weiß ich, das ist in meiner Timeline hier drin.
Aber ich meine, es wäre doch eigentlich ganz cool, wenn das bei Podcasts auch so wäre. Ich meine, zumindest als optionale Sache wäre das doch wirklich großartig, wenn Instacast so was drin hätte. Hey, ich hab gerade mit Instacast das und das gehört. Oder höre das und lach mir einen ab. Und höre live mit, damit auch dein Live-Feeling wieder aufkommt.
Du kannst dir auch noch einen Like machen, wenn das dir wirklich gut gefallen hat. Dagegen kann man nichts sagen. Und wenn dann hintenrum Flette, auch mit einem Facebook-Connected, was sie wahrscheinlich auch schon machen werden, und dann einfach mal alle Podcasts abgrasen kann, oder jemand schreibt eine App, die das macht, und die dann autoflettert, dann ist es halt, dann kann man Instacast nicht in die Schuhe schieben und auch nicht fletter. Aber du hast halt deine Funktionalität wieder ohne jetzt irgendwie noch einen dritten Service, den du gar keinen Bock hast.
Ja, also ich denke, dass generell diese Favoriten auswerten und dann automatisch darauf was tun, nur mal, dass wir von der Idee noch viel hören werden, glaube ich, zu den nächsten Wochen und Monaten. Das macht einfach total Sinn. Also das ganze Geherze und Gesterne, das kann man dann dann sozusagen auch in wirklichem Dank umsetzen.
Gesternen.
Ja, das ist dann nicht immer so...
Besternungsinstitut.
Pfaff langsam.
Der hat mir, der hat Mara letztens, ich hab letztens mit Mara gespießen, ja, und der meinte, er hatte sich fürchterlich über diese Die Hard Übersetzung aufgeregt, weil das ja überhaupt nichts mit Sterben zu tun hätte.
Die Hard? Sondern?
Na, das ist halt so wie Die Hard Republican oder so, also so irgendwie.
Dass man ein Die Hard ist.
Und dann irgendwie stirbt langsam wie reine Gräßlich. Ganz gräßlich.
Als Kritiker, wie bin ich dumm, Dreck befassen?
Ja. Wir als Kritiker müssen uns ja auch mit einer Menge Dreck befassen. Haben wir denn noch mehr Dreck?
Überall.
Heute ist IPv6-Tag. Und Denis ist nicht da.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich bin schon total IPv6. Du bist total IPv6.
Ja.
Klingt aber auch ein bisschen an einer anstrengenden Karte.
Was müssen denn unsere Hörer jetzt machen?
Was die Hörer machen müssen?
Ja, was müssen sie machen?
Naja, also, wenn sie, kommt halt drauf an, also wenn man zu Hause IPv6 haben will, dann muss man sicher, wie wir es schon mal zu vor kurzem...
Sag mal lieber, warum man IPv6 haben will.
Damit man das Internet so hat, wie es früher eigentlich mal für jeden war, nämlich ungenattet und mit echten IP-Adressen für jedermann. Das hat so seine Vorteile, das hat auch natürlich ein paar Risiken, aber eigentlich nicht so viel. Also zum Beispiel bei IPv4 ist es halt so, da gibt es nicht so viele Adressen von. Das heißt, die ganzen Script-Kitties scannen permanent alle Netze und versuchen in die Maschinen einzubrechen, weil die IPs gibt es seit je und je. Da kannst du halt mal durchscannen, das geht schon. Bei IPv6 gibt es einfach so viele Adressen. Selbst wenn du da ein scheiß Passwort hast und irgendeinen Service hast, der scheunentorweit offen steht, bis den mal einer quasi gescannt hat. Also es kann natürlich, ein blindes Huhn findet immer einen Korn und so weiter, aber auch mal einen Korn. Aber ist jetzt nicht so super gefährlich. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, also... Und dann war jetzt ja die Frage, wie könnte man denn so als Hörer dieser Sendung jetzt zu diesem IPv6-Spektakel kommen und daran teilnehmen und seine Hände drin baden? Da hatten wir ja zum Beispiel in einer unserer vorherigen Sendungen schon gesagt, wenn man sich das alte Apple Airport Utility 5.6 herunterlädt und eine Airport Base Station besitzt, kann man zum Beispiel einstellen, dass man dieses 624 automatisch bekommt. Das funktioniert vor allen Dingen dann, wenn diese Airport Base Station dann mit dem Warnport direkt am Internet hängt. Also angenommen hat ein DSL-Modem und man führt ein Ethernet-Kabel zum Warnport seiner Airport Station und stellt dann mit dem alten Airport Utility-624 ein. Dann hat man auch IPv6 zu Hause.
Traumhaft.
Und was haben wir da davon?
Public IP-Adresse. Ungenattet.
Die alle drei anderen IPv... Nein, es sind ein paar mehr. IPv6-Nerds auch aufrufen können.
Also es sind mittlerweile tatsächlich... Also ich hab schon viel V6 immer so um mich rum und ich benutze ja auch BitTorrent, um Wikipedia-Dumps runterzuladen, Open-Street-Net-Dumps und so weiter und sofort OpenOffice runterzuladen, Podcasts natürlich. Und ich sehe da schon signifikante Anteile V6-Clients jetzt mittlerweile. Das können natürlich auch vor allen Dingen Leute sein, die in ihrem Hosting-Center auf dem Server die Torrent-Clients laufen lassen, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es da. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass irgendwie man ein V6-Adresse hat und nirgends wohin könnte. Also alle großen Webseiten im Prinzip kannst du auch schon mit V6 erreichen.
Team Mobile USA haben die heute in ihrem Netz freigeschaltet, in ihrem Mobilfunknetz IPv6. Sind die die erste Provider damit?
Also von den Mobilfunk-Providern sind sie glaube ich einer der ersten. Bei den anderen Providern, also ich glaube Comcast in den USA, hat auch schon an die Endkunden V6 ausgerollt. Alle großen Hoster in Deutschland haben auch schon V6-Hetzner, Domain Factory, Host Europe, ok, einzelne Strato weiß ich ehrlich gesagt, nicht genau, aber eigentlich kriegst du schon überall V6 um die Ohren geworfen. Das Einzige, was jetzt eigentlich fehlt...
Das sind die IP-Adressen wahrscheinlich saubillig.
Du kriegst sie kostenlos im Wesentlichen. Also bei Hetzner kannst du halt sagen, ja hier ich hätte gerne eine V4-Adresse, ja gut, kostet eine Euro pro Monat. Achso und wenn du willst, kannst du aber einen Slash64 IPv6 kostenlos haben. Also damit werfen sie wirklich... Ja, genau. Und ja, das sind eigentlich so die essentiellen Wege. Entweder dein Internet-Service Provider entscheidet sich demnächst auch mal an die Endkunden V6 rauszugeben, was sie auch tun werden. Weil V4 ist halt tatsächlich alle. Das heißt, wenn jetzt... Also sie haben ja alle noch Kontingente an V4-Adressen, aber die gehen halt tatsächlich rapide zur Neige und ja.
Ich hab ja so eine Vermutung, dass es da in vielen Unternehmen so losgehen wird, dass sobald sie alle sind, sie spontan eine Notfallgruppe gründen werden, die sich jetzt um dieses spontan auftretende Problem kümmert.
Das Ding ist halt, die Provider haben noch eine Übergangslösung. Was die machen, ist halt so genanntes Carrier-Grade-Nut. Das heißt, sie machen das Nut auf Carrier-Seite und sozusagen du kriegst schon auf deinem DSL-Modem keine echte Public-V4-Adresse mehr.
Also bin ich doppelt genuttet.
Und dann kriegst du eben dieses Dual-Stack, kriegst du eben noch echtes V6 dazu. Das heißt, im Wesentlichen will man dann früher oder später auch eher V6 benutzen als eben Carrier-Grade-Nut. Aber du wirst so oder so eine ganze Zeit lang beides haben, sodass du immer noch auch die alten V4-Adressen, wenn Services nur auf V4 gehen, auch noch die erreichen kannst. Aber prinzipiell, ja, V6 ist schon an sich cooler. Wie gesagt, kriegst halt vom Provider in Slash64, also auch als Endkunde bei der Telekom oder sonst was, kriegst du einfach zu Hause Slash64 Netz zu deiner freien Verfügung. Das ist halt, da kannst du eben deiner Körperbehaarungs- Dinge eine V6-Adresse geben und hättest immer noch tausendmal mehr. Nee, aber ich hab jetzt, wie gesagt, das hatte ich ja auch letztens erzählt, ich hab bei Hetzner jetzt auch mir einen privaten Server geholt und meine ganzen Webseiten nachher umgezogen und die sind natürlich auch über V6 schon erreicht. Selbstverständlich.
Natürlich.
Adel verpflichtet.
Wenn das mal so einfach wäre, also ich meine unter FreeBSD ist das ja immer noch nicht Standard.
Wie?
Achso, nee, naja gut. Mussten auch deinen IPv6-Enable sagen, ja. Aber ansonsten.
Also mir würde gesagt, dass diese ganzen Jails... Dass nicht serienmäßig so ein Standard Out of the Box FreeBSD hat keinen V6 in Jails. Sondern du musst da irgendeinen komischen Support noch mit reinkompilen.
Nee, nee, nee, es geht. Hab ich gemacht.
Ich hab grad so ein totales Digital-Tür.
Genau. Ja, das hast du letztes Mal schon behauptet.
Ja, aber dann hab ich noch mal bei meinem...
Der hat gelogen.
Nachgefragt und die haben steif und fest behauptet, das sei nicht so.
Also ich hab so ein Freebies installiert.
Oder Achter.
Auch beim Achter schon. Da hast du IPv6 Enable, konfigurierst da deine Adressen, kannst in deiner Jail-Config sagen, hier, du hast eine V4-Adresse, du hast eine V6-Adresse, boom geht. Also, da leg ich meine Hand sogar fast dafür ins Feuer. Aber nur fast.
Vielleicht sollte man ein bisschen schimpfen?
Sag mir deren Namen und ich werde sie auf Twitter verunglimpfen.
Ich würde sagen, ich gebe ihnen noch eine Chance. Vielleicht haben sie mich falsch verstanden.
Also, bei mir funktioniert es keine Ahnung. Ich habe da nicht groß irgendwas getan.
Yay, Apple V6 ist toll, wir freuen uns alle.
Wer von euch im Raum hat denn V6-Services schon deployed?
Ich.
Nicht all of aeim.
Ach so, Services, du meinst anbieten.
Hast du eine Webseite, die auf V6 ist? Mobile Max V6 erreichbar.
Das ist alles halt in FreeBSD-Jails, wo ich von ausgegangen bin, dass da kein V6 geht. Das geht. Das geht.
Und du?
Ich hoste alles als GitHub-Pages. Und die haben bestimmt IPv6.
Ja, Rackspace war tatsächlich auch einer der ersten Provider. Aber jetzt machen wir mal den Test. ping6github.com Ach, wir haben ja natürlich keinen V6, muss ich vom Server machen.
Hier sollte es V6 gehen.
V6 www.came.net So, die Klassiker, tatsächlich. Wir haben hier V6, aber Google hat keinen V6.
Da muss ich umziehen.
Du kannst zum Beispiel smig.net glaube ich mit V6 pingen.
Also ich hab nichts gegen V6 einzurichten. Ich find das toll und ich finde das ist definitiv eine spannende Technologie und das muss kommen. Die Provider müssen schnell hin. Aber im Augenblick hab ich doch ehrlich gesagt immer noch das Gefühl, dass es eher so eine Bastelei ist.
Das Ding ist, man sollte sich auch früh wie möglich mal damit auseinandergesetzt haben, weil irgendwann, früher oder später, eher früher als später sogar, wird man damit konfrontiert. Und wenn man dann erst anfangen muss, ist es halt auch ein bisschen mühsam manchmal.
Das stimmt. Außerdem ordentliche Erreichbarkeit mit ohne Nutscheiße, das ist einfach mal so nötig wie...
Ja, es ist schon echt ein cooles Feature.
Gut, wenn man das braucht, dann ist das super.
Also wenn man so eine Fritzbox hat, dann ist das wirklich super einfach. Dann geht man einfach zu diesen 6XS. Ich hab's schon mal erzählt, S-I-X-S. Und da kannst du dir kostenlos da irgendwie was klicken. Da kriegst du so ein Punto-Konto, wenn du dir ein Account machst. Und davon kannst du dir dann erstmal einen Adressatz geben lassen. Und dann kriegst du so Zugangsdaten. Das kannst du in so einer Fritzbox direkt eintragen. Und dann macht die Fritzbox mit dem 6XS sozusagen aus. Mit hier, was ist denn mein Netzwerk-Range? Und dann kriegst du den von dort. Und der wird dann hier im internen Netz so verbreitet, als wäre das vom Provider gekommen. Und du kriegst dann weitere Punkte von 6XS, wenn du das auch betreibst. Das heißt, die belohnen die Benutzung. Davon kannst du ja dann eben weitere Dinge und Details da klicken. Ich weiß gar nicht, was die da alles sonst noch im Angebot haben.
Ja, und wie das 6to4 ist halt an sich eigentlich auch ein ganz geiler Hack. Weil man muss halt auch nicht wirklich was groß tun. Also 6to4 ist halt sozusagen die Konvertierung von IPv6 nach IPv4 und andersrum. Und man muss nicht mal wirklich zum Provider, nur wenn man halt wirklich ein festes Netz haben will. Ja, und das tut total super. Kann man in der Wikipedia nachlesen, hat man eine halbe Stunde aufgesetzt. Muss man nicht erklären. Gut, also IPv6-Tag, wir haben dir gehuldigt. Ihr lieben Hörerlein, nächste Hausaufgabe war glaube ich schon letzte Hausaufgabe, alle mal die Webseiten auf V6 umstellen. Oder zumindest mal eine. Das ist wie gesagt so zu Übungszwecken, weil es kommt so oder so. Und ihr wollt alle nicht Carrier-Grade-Nut haben. Stimmt's?
Also mir ist es ehrlich gesagt tatsächlich relativ wurscht. Aber ich hab bisher noch keine großen Nachteile dadurch bemerkt.
Du hast ja auch noch keinen Carrier-Grade-Nut.
Ich weiß den Ehrgeiz sehr zu schätzen. Kann ich hier irgendwo für meinen Server noch mir eine...
Du hast jetzt schon eine IPv6 da wahrscheinlich.
Nein, bei Hetzner musst du glaube ich...
IPs, Zeige-Traffic-Statistiken, IP-Adressen.
Irgendwo könnte man da dazubuchen. Wo war denn das mit dem Dazubuchen von den Features hier? Du kannst ja irgendwann noch eine IP-Adresse bestellen. Dann hier, wenn man da zack.
Zusätzliche IPs. Kostenlos. Oh, ich sollte da vielleicht mal meine Adresse ändern bei denen. Die ist nämlich falsch mittlerweile.
Das ist doch vielleicht nicht schlecht, wenn in deinem Whois-Record eine falsche Adresse steht. Naja, siehst du, also kannst du klicken, dann schreiben sie dir gleich eine Mail mit den Setup-Daten und dann hast du das auch auf deiner Heiznachmaschine.
Na gut, dann hab ich jetzt auch IPv6. Mal gucken, wann ich darunter auch erreichbar bin. Wahrscheinlich muss ich da noch irgendwas... Ich hab da ein Ubuntu drauf laufen.
Und jetzt die spannende Preisfrage, ist denn Bit.Lav, der Torrent-Trecker der Weltrevolution, schon V6?
Alles komplett V6, von vorne bis hinten und oben bis unten.
V6, von vorne bis hinten, V6 dich so durch.
Astro ist ja auch so ein totaler Netz-Nerd. Da werd ich jetzt gleich was von berichten.
Ja, erstmal werd ich hier ein bisschen berichten.
Also Max ist schon Erster, ne?
Ich hab ja auch mehr.
Wollt mich auch nicht vordringen.
Hab auch mehr als du hier. Ich hab mir nämlich hier so ein, wie heißt das, Tilt-Pod gekauft.
Produktplatzierung.
Produktplatzierung. Hat mich irgendwie 15 Dollar gekostet, Versand war relativ teuer. Das ist so ein kleines Stativ für den Schlüsselanhänger. Und zwar ist das hier so eine kleine Platte, so Schlüsselanhänger.
Aus Blei.
Also das ist ein Stativ fürs iPhone.
Fürs iPhone, ja genau. Aber du kannst ja die Schlüsselanhänger dran machen. Und dann steckt man hier das Telefon so rein und dann steht das da so drin.
Ist das aus Blei oder warum hat das so einen Stand?
Hochkant wird problematisch. Also im Querformat geht's gut.
Das geht auch.
Im Hochformat geht's auch. Kann man zum Facetime-Ufonieren oder zum Fotografieren nutzen. Oder wenn man einfach hier so Filme drauf gucken will oder so was, dann ist das eine ganz praktische Sache. Ist auch so als Schlüsselanhänger, finde ich jetzt, nicht so unglaublich hässlich. Also ist jetzt so, keine Ahnung. Hab auf jeden Fall mal was, warum ich meinen Schlüssel erkenne. Besser als so dämlicher USB-Stick, den man nie benutzt.
Wenn da so ein iPhone in deinem Schlüsselbund hängt.
Wie heißt dieses Gerät?
Tiltpod.
T-I-L-T-Pod.
Genau.
Und was sehr schick ist, da ist so ein Kugelgelenk.
Ah ja, hier. Ach was, das war ein Kickstarter-Projekt?
Und es ist halt mit so Magneten. Da ist unten so eine Fläche und da wird per Magnet dieses Kugelgelenk drauf gelagert, sodass man das wirklich...
Alterverwalter.
Damit man das oben drehen kann. Damit ich den Kopf drehen kann, damit ich das iPhone wirklich in jeder beliebigen Position drehen kann.
Gib mal her, ich muss das mal ein bisschen...
Krass, 63.000 haben die auf Kickstarter dafür bekommen.
Das ist schon nicht unklapp, oder?
Cool, Omaat.
Ich hätte mich schon gefragt, ob das nicht dann irgendwann bricht, aber da gibt es ja gar nichts, was brechen kann.
Ich weiß nicht viel, was brechen kann. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange der das Magnet durchhält. Und mal gucken, wie kompatibel es da mit einem iPhone 5 sein wird.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, bis der Magnet nicht mehr magnetisch ist, hast du schon dreimal das iPhone gewechselt.
Aber so kann man dann jede beliebige Position einnehmen. Das ist ganz geil eigentlich.
Das ist schon ganz cool, ne?
Und so für senkrecht? Naja, also wenn man den Schlüsselanhänger noch strategisch als Gegengewicht benutzt.
Da muss das da, das ist schon nicht lang genug, da musst du es andersrum reinstecken quasi.
Die Schnur ist nicht lang genug?
Der Magnet ist nicht stark genug, dem Hebel entgegenzuwirken.
Naja, das ist weniger der Hebel, das Problem ist das Unterteil.
Seien Sie auch nächstes Mal dabei, wenn bei Mobimax die iPhones kaputt gemacht werden.
Na gut, aber wer will schon sein Telefon irgendwie...
Also im Hochformat ist es wirklich...
Okay, also es eignet sich für Querformat.
Genau, so ein kleines Stativ, was man immer dabei hat.
Was kostet der Spaß?
15 Dollar plus Versand. Versand war relativ teuer.
100 Euro.
Keine Ahnung, wieso 7 Euro.
Du musstest dir das aus den USA kommen lassen.
Ich hab's mir direkt aus den USA einfliegen lassen.
Aus den Vereinigten Staaten.
Hätte ich mir auch schön zu...
Kannst du mich da mal ein paar mitbringen? Ihr fahrt doch hier alle in den USA. Wenn einer eine Reise tut, dann muss es natürlich auch...
Dann ins Hotel schicken lassen irgendwie.
Nö, da gibt's einfach dann auch Reisegeschenke.
Achso, wir sollen ja was...
Du hast ja keine Kinder, dann kannst du uns ja was mitbringen.
Achso, so ist das gedacht.
Rollen nicht.
So, dann hab ich mir noch so ein...
Befresse ich den Brownie weg jetzt?
So ein iRig-Mic geholt. Das ist so ein Mikrofon, was man oben an den Kopfhöreranschluss vom iPhone anschließen kann. Hat man so ein kleines, hübsches, wie Huckel schon richtig bemerkte, stinkendes Mikro in der Hand. Also die Tasche ist eigentlich das, was riecht. Das ist so echtes Kunstleder.
Aus imitiertem Lederimitat.
Aber das funktioniert. Also das Mikro ist aber in sich geil. Also das macht eine gute Qualität. Man hat ja noch so einen Anschluss, wo man dann noch zusätzlich...
Aber ich dachte, iRig ist so ein Gitarrengeschrammeln.
Ja, die haben jetzt auch ein Mikrofon. Es gibt auch den iRig-Mikrofonadapter. Hat oben noch einen Kopfhörerausgang.
Aber was leistet denn dieser Adapter?
Also ich meine...
Das ist ein komplettes Mikro.
Wir reden von einem dynamischen Mikrofon.
Wenn du es sagst, dann wird das schon schön. Also es braucht keine Batterien oder dergleichen.
Ja.
Ich hab hier drei Einstellungsmodi, mit dem ich die Empfindlichkeit einstellen kann. Sodass ich so wieviel Hintergrundgeräusche hätte ich da gerne drauf. Es hat einen Kopfhörerausgang oben, mit dem man dann gleichzeitig sich monitoren kann. Das können viele Marken, Aufnahmeprogramme...
iRig-Mig.
Ich kann auch gerne mal eine Hörprobe aufnehmen.
Mach doch mal eine Hörprobe.
Und man muss halt in der entsprechenden App das Monitoring einschalten. Die Soundcloud-App hat keine Monitoring-Durchleitung, aber Garage Band hat's. Also mit Garage Band kann man schön aufnehmen. Die Latenz ist...
Garage Band?
Also auf IOS?
Auf IOS, hier beim Durchleiten von diesem ganzen Zeug. Und ja, das wollte ich dann zur WWDC mitnehmen, mal gucken, was man damit so anstellen kann, ob man vielleicht mal so ein paar Leute befragen oder im Flugzeug oder weiß der Teufel was, gucken, was da passiert. Das war so ein bisschen der Gedanke. Und wenn man ein hinreichend neues MacBook hat, dann funktioniert das natürlich auch am MacBook ganz hervorragend. Also das Mikro, das kann man auch einfach so an den Kopfhörerausgang von seinem MacBook anschließen und kann darüber aufnehmen.
Gut. Und da ist keine Batterie drin?
Da ist keine Batterie drin.
Okay, also es handelt sich tatsächlich um ein Kondensatormikrofon, also ein Elektretmikrofon mit Kugelcharakteristik. Was ganz interessant ist, weil müsste ja eigentlich auch ein bisschen Strom irgendwie da reintun, weil ein Elektret...
Ein bisschen Strom müsste ja auch darüber kommen, oder?
Ich kann ja hier mal so mit...
Und was allerdings wirklich furchtbar ist, die legen natürlich dann so eine Lite-Version von irgendeiner Aufnahmesoftware dazu, iRig, Vocal, irgendwas. Kann man sich auch so im App Store runterladen. Und das ist wirklich eine Frechheit. Also das Ding ist nicht Retina-tauglich.
Was heißt, sie legen das bei?
Na ja, sagen, lad dir das runter.
Aber es sieht hübsch aus.
Sie legen ein Link bei.
Sie legen ein... Nee, nicht mal das, sondern sie sagen, lad dir das aus dem Store runter. Dann oben guckt ihr mal an, da ist oben die Statusbar, wo die Uhrzeit drinne steht, ist ausgeblendet, nur damit da iRig.mic drinne stehen kann. Also sie bringen keine zusätzliche Information da drinnen unter, sondern es ist einfach... Und es ist, also die kostenlose Version, die dabei ist, die ist wirklich ein Witz. Also das erste, was du startest, die, dann wirst du hey, like unsere Seite auf Facebook, dann kriegst du zusätzliche Features freigeschaltet und dann kriegst du bei jedem Start irgendwie kauf noch das dazu, kauf noch das dazu, kauf noch das dazu und das finde ich echt eine Unverschämtheit bei so einem scheiße teuren...
So, aber es hat da noch einen Kopfhörerausgang mit dabei.
Hier ist ein Kopfhörerausgang, kannst du alles durchschleifen. Dann kann man das ja auch alles... Hat der überhaupt hier Aufnahme? Ah, hier ist der Aufnahmemodus von...
Das ist eigentlich ganz interessant.
Und man hat auch so einen lustigen Chipmark-Modus.
Was kostet das Ding?
49 Dollar.
49 Euro, ja, ich hab's ja. Ich nehme jetzt hier mal ein bisschen auf und das kann man nachher dann noch mit auf die Seite draufpacken. Das ist jetzt so der mittlere Modus, jetzt mach ich mal den ganz empfindlichen Modus. Jetzt müsste man euch eigentlich mithören, wenn ihr was sagen wollt.
Oh mein Gott, das schlägt total aus!
Schau dir das an.
Ja gut, dass ich jetzt schon die Schaltz habe. Und dass man Tim nicht mehr hört. Das sieht gar nicht aus. Achso, man kann hier aber noch...
Das ist doch jetzt Garage Band, oder was?
Das ist jetzt Garage Band, genau.
Kannste gleich auf Facebook sharen.
Oder Soundcloud.
Ich hab ja meine Band in meiner eigenen Garage.
Nee, aber ist ja Soundcloud-Integration drin. Das heißt, ich kann auf der WWDC das aufnehmen, kanns direkt hochladen, in die Wolke und das aus der Tasche raus. Ah, ich hätte mal die Rekordtasse aufgenommen zu recorden. Ich stelle mich dafür ein bisschen doof an. Na gut, ich pack das nachher mal online.
Ja, das liegt auch ganz gut in der Hand. Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so ein leichtes Billigplaste-Feeling.
Ja, das ist erstaunlich, weil sie es so schwer gemacht haben. Schwierig Billigplaste.
Auch so mit Metall und alles.
Lass mal anfassen.
Mich oder das Mikro?
Tja, Mobamex geht direkt in den intimen Bereich vor.
Aber wär's nicht besser, einfach nur ein XLR-Stecker?
Nö, nicht unbedingt, weil XLR, ich meine, hast ja eigentlich alles dran. Du kannst ja auch so einen Kopfhörer ranmachen. Im Prinzip, ich frage mich halt, ich hätte halt sowas gerne, sagen wir mal, ohne Mikrofon, dass man ein beliebiges Mikrofon ranstecken kann. Ich frage mich nur die ganze Zeit wieder, wie die das mit der Speisespannung machen.
Speisespannung?
Und was man eigentlich aus so einem iPhone über einen Kopfhörerausgang an Speisespannung generieren kann. Wahrscheinlich gar keine.
Boah, es gibt ja sogar einen Mixer für das.
Einfaches Elektrieteil.
Die bauen ja alles hier.
Ja, die haben da echt ganz schön viel.
Es gibt eine Universal Microphone Interface für iPhone und iPad. Für 30 Euro. Also von denen gibt es ja tatsächlich echt viel. Audio, Mobil, Foo.
Und dieser Gitarrenadapter, der ist ja mittlerweile auch relativ legendär schon, weil der ganz gut ist.
Guck mal, da, Tim, klickste.
Klick ich wo?
Da, iRig Pre.
Letzter Link hier von mir. Und da hast du dann XLR. Und auch so ein Kopfhörer durchgeschleift.
48 Volt.
Und wo kommt da der Kopfhörer raus?
Na, irgendwie steht da...
Na oben direkt neben denen, da sind ja zwei, also, sie hat das eine Kabel, das zum iPhone geht, dann direkt daneben der Kopfhöreradapter und unten dann der XLR.
Aber sie zeigen den Ausgang nicht.
Ja, aber es wird schon... Das ist linke sein, nicht?
Das wird eine dreieinhalb Millimeter-Klinke sein.
Wird sein, wird sein. Was heißt wird sein?
Steht hier bestimmt auch noch... Zeigen.
Erklären.
Steht keine explizite dran, dann ist es dreieinhalb Millimeter.
Ja, warte, wir gucken hier nicht Specs, das steht erst so bestimmt.
Wir bestellen und dann gucken wir.
Ach nee, da steht es nicht tatsächlich.
Das macht ja auch total Sinn, weil dann kann man nämlich seinen iPhone-Kopferer, den man mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit sowieso dabei hat, kann man dann einfach zusätzlich anschließen und dann hat man...
Da macht man eine Batterie rein oder was?
Da muss man bestimmt eine Batterie rein machen, oder?
Also er meint hier 48 Volt Phantom-Power. Provided bei 9 Volt Batterie.
9 Volt Batterie.
Geilo.
Kauf ich.
30 Euro.
Siehst du, Live-Produktberatung hier wieder. Wollen sie vielleicht noch andere? Also den Mixer hast du auch gesehen, den sie da haben, ja?
Der sieht echt nicht schlecht aus, oder?
Der sieht schon ganz funky aus auf jeden Fall. Mit zwei iPads DJ machen, geil.
Den Mixer, meinst du Software jetzt, oder?
Nee, den DJ-Teil dann. Ioric Mix. Aber da geht wirklich nur Klinke dann rein, oder? Wie sieht das aus?
Ja, ich glaube, das hat keinen... Na, die drücken sich auch vor dem Dock-Connector. Das wird natürlich, ach schade, das ist die WWDC-Sache, die wir so ein bisschen vergessen haben. Bluetooth 4, da wird irgendwas kommen, hoffe ich mal. Ich hoffe, dass das so richtig spannend wird.
Was sind denn die Vorteile von Bluetooth 4?
Na, dass man nicht mehr an diesem Apple-Irgendwas-Programm teilnehmen muss, um seine eigene Hardware, um den eigenen Chip da nutzen zu dürfen von denen, sondern dass das weitgehend durchgenetisiert ist und man da wirklich so ziemlich alles drüber machen kann. Ich weiß, das war jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr konkret und für die Nicht-Techniker... Ich fand's ein bisschen zu detailliert eigentlich. Ja, ich weiß.
Kannst du das noch ein bisschen abstrakter umschreiben?
Ja, die haben echt Mikrofone in diversen... Der heißt sogar Cast hier.
Ja, Mik-Cast. Für die ganz simplen Ansprüche.
Für die ganz simplen. Naja, wenn man einfach mal so ein Mikrofon braucht, um jemand unter die Fresse zu halten, das ist schon... Das passt fast ins Portemonnaie rein, das Ding. Das ist schon... Und haben die da... Da ist aber noch der Ständer dabei, ne? So ein kleiner Ständer, an dem man das iPhone auch aufstellen kann. Weil bei den meisten dieser Dinger ist es ja, die gibt's ja auch für einen Dock-Anschluss unten. Da ist mir aber von abgeraten worden, weil du hast halt dieses Problem, du musst das Mikro dann auf den Tisch legen direkt. Du musst das iPhone dann auf den Tisch packen und sobald du das irgendwie anfasst, hast du irgendwelche Störgeräusche drauf. Und dafür ist natürlich so ein externes Mikrofon, so was du per Kabel dran hast, wesentlich besser. Das kannst du weiterhin bedienen, ohne dass du irgendwelche Störgeräusche hast.
Der Wahnsinn!
Ja, wartet da nicht, alles gibt, ne?
Der Wahnsinn in Tüten.
Vielleicht noch das dritte Gimmick quasi. Wir steigen jetzt langsam in der Schwachsinnigkeitsgrasa hier.
Wieso? Also erst so.
Jetzt hab ich noch das, den... Ich wandere schon seit Jahren um so ein iPad-Stift rum. Und ich war hier ehrlich gesagt nicht bereit für diesen... Du hast so einen Bamboo-Stylus, ne? So diesen superdicken Bleistift, der aus...
Aber es ist nicht der dickste. Also es gibt noch viel dickere. Der Bamboo war schon die gehobenere Dünnheitsklasse.
Das stimmt. Jetzt hast du dieses Teil, was damals nur versprochen worden ist.
Und ich hab mir jetzt hier so ein Jot Pro geholt. Jot Pro, keine Ahnung, J-O-T Pro. Und das ist so, ist heute angekommen. Also ich hab jetzt selber noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel mit rumspielen können. Aber das macht einen sehr präzisen Eindruck. Und damit kann ich mir echt vorstellen, auch mal so irgendwie was ein bisschen so durchaus mal zu malen oder auch ein bisschen mitzuschreiben. Okay, jetzt hab ich jetzt...
Lyric Pre gibt's übrigens noch gar nicht. Pre-Order Now.
Na dann pre-order doch Now.
Ja, dann pre-order hier mal.
Naja, Nuasa oder was.
Das hast du nur noch bei Kickstarter gekauft, oder?
Das ist eigentlich nicht bei Kickstarter gekauft. Das war ganz normal bei Amazon.
Scheint auch so ein Kickstarter-Ding zu sein.
Ja, ist doch alles hier Kickstarter.
Ist doch alles Kickstarter.
Es gibt doch kein iPhone-Zubehör. Kickstarter ist doch diese iPhone-Zubehör-Plattform.
Also langsam kann man schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck gewinnen.
Oder Adventure Games.
Diese Plastikscheibe, also wenn da so ein bisschen Dreck drunter kommt und du da fleißig einmal rumrotieren müsst, dann...
Ja, das muss ich mir nochmal genauer angucken, wie das hier so alles. Wobei ich hab auch das Gefühl, dass das je nach App sehr viel, sehr stark wechselt. Vielleicht kann man hier, würde mich nicht mal wundern, wenn man hier noch die Präzision einstellen kann.
Was ist ein Eyedropper?
Das ist diese Pipette.
Das ist so schön, dass deine Eis aufs Pet droppt. Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen harter Anschlag. Die anderen Stifte haben dann so einen schönen Schaumball, der das dann auch sehr weich zum Tippen macht. Wenn du da drauf haust, dann machst du auch gleich richtig Bam, bam, bam!
Vielleicht dann so bei der Keynote. Ah nee, das geht auch so gar nicht mehr. Hey, wer ist das denn hier für ein Mercury-Stift? Ich stell mich da offensichtlich zu doof für an für dieses.
Geht das jetzt gut mit dem Ding?
Achso, ich hab die falsche Farbe.
Ich glaub, er hat die falsche ab, vor allen Dingen.
Nee, ich hab hier mit dem Eyedropper eine falsche Farbe ausgewählt und hab die ganze Zeit probiert, mit Weiß zu malen. Und plötzlich ging's nicht mehr.
Ein Drama.
Viele bei diesem, Gott, bei diesem Procreate, die haben da echt viele Stifte in verschiedensten Arten. Kann auch mit Texturen malen.
Bist du durch mit deinem Stift?
Ja, kannst du ganz ruhig erzählen.
Okay, dann will ich euch noch ein anderes, wunderbares Produkt vorstellen.
Wunder der Technik.
Wunder der Technik. Manche Sachen sind ja wirklich so einfach, dass man sich echt am Kopf haut.
Das sieht so aus wie was, was ich haben will.
Kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Das ist der Belkin, wer ist das Ding nochmal?
Rockstar.
Auch in Sternform, passender Name. Es handelt sich hier zunächst einmal um einen 6-köpfigen Miniklinkenverteiler. Achso, ich dachte, ein Kabel ist fest drin. Also genau genommen sind es 5 Steckerchen und ein Kabel ist vorgegeben. Also kannst 5 Miniklinken da reinstecken. Und ein Kabel ist quasi vorgegeben, was du auch irgendwo reinstecken kannst. Jetzt kannst du damit folgendes machen. Du kannst da das Kabel in dein iPhone reinstecken. Dann hängt dieser Stern dann an deinem iPhone dran. Dann kannst du halt 5 Kopfhörer anschließen. Oder du schließt noch ein iPhone an. Oder, was mein Anwendungsgebiet ist, warum ich mir das Ding gekauft habe, ich mach hier nochmal so ein Klinke-Klinkekabel rein und schließ mein Mac an. Das ist nämlich meine klassische Reiseproblematik, dass ich sowohl auf meinem Mac irgendwas abspielen will, hören will, einen Film gucke oder sonst irgendwas, aber ab und zu auch mal auf meinem Telefon dabei sein will, so Podcasts hören oder keine Ahnung, was man halt immer so macht. Oder allein, um nur die schönen Töne zu hören oder vielleicht kommt die Musik eben von da und nebenbei fummelst du noch in irgendeiner bekloppten Aufnahme rum und möchtest aber auch, also möchtest einfach beides haben und möchtest es gerne mixen. Und das geht einfach mit diesem Teil. Du kannst also an jedem Port entweder einen Kopfhörer oder einen Zuspieler einspielen. Und das ist ganz einfach.
Der ist nicht doof.
Schon cool.
Und es ist kompakt und löst einfach und vor allem auch so dieses willst irgendwie zwei Leuten dann mal was vorspielen. Hast du auch irgendwie genug Kopfhörer oder hast halt diese blöde Weiche?
Ja oder zwei Leute wollen einen Film gucken und da ist noch jemand, der keinen Bock auf Film hat und dann darf nicht laut gespielt werden, dann gibt es keinen Kopfhörer.
Wie ich neulich im Zug, da wollte ich dann alles gucken.
Ja genau, im Zug zum Beispiel auch.
Also entweder ein Kopfhörer hört mehrere Quellen oder mehrere Kopfhörer hören eine Quelle oder mehrere Quellen und mehrere Kopfhörer, das geht irgendwie alles.
Klick ich mir doch gleich mal auf Amazon.
Ja, ist sehr sozial, würde ich sagen. Also ist ein soziales Gerät für den Menschen des 21.
Den gibt es einmal für 15 Euro und einmal für 9 Euro.
Wenn ihr in einem sozialen Netzwerk seid, dann wollt ihr auch den sozialen Verteilerstecker haben.
Aber wieso kostet der einmal 5 Euro?
Das klang jetzt einmal wirklich.
Was?
Sozialer Verteilerstecker.
Könnte man nicht damit eine Skype-Konferenz aufmachen? Oder eine Facetime-Konferenz?
Hätte es noch 500 Anschlüsse mehr, dann wär's in Deutschland schon Rundfunk.
Ja, das sogar ohne Skype.
Ist denn bei diesem Wunder der Technik dieses zweite Klinke-Kabel auch dabei, das Klinke-Klinke?
Ja, das ist schon dabei. Alles, was hier grün ist, ist dabei. Ist dabei.
Ist ja ein Traum.
Ja, es ist sozusagen wirklich Kulomat. Kostet irgendwie ein Zehner maximal.
Ist schon quasi im Amazon. Oh, ich hab noch was im Amazon-Einkaufswagen.
Amazon, Amazon. Ja, das ist eine tolle Sache. Was auch noch eine tolle Sache ist, das ist das, was hast du mich neulich mal draufgebracht. Jetzt hab ich leider vergessen, wie das Ding heißt.
Wer ist denn du in dem Fall?
Le Ueckle hat nämlich mir erzählt, dass er stecke seine Festplatte in Gerät. Und Gerät heißt, hab ich vergessen. Muss ich schlagen nach, wie Gerät heißt. Aber du weißt wahrscheinlich schon, was ich meine, oder?
Aber ich spuck's aus. Nein, warte.
Du weißt es auch nicht mehr.
Das beruhigt mich.
Ich bin hier total verwirrt. Achso, das sind die Versandkosten.
Scharkun heißt das Gerät. S-H-A-R-K-O-O-N. Und das ist so ein Stück Plastik. Brauchbar stabil.
Was macht das?
Und das ist einfach ein Festplatten-
Dock.
USB-Adapter-Dock, genau, wo du einfach die Festplatten senkrecht in so Slots reinsteckst.
Achso, sagt das.
Das geht sowohl mit kleinen 2,5 Zoll, als auch mit 3,5 Zoll Platten. Das heißt, du steckst die einfach so von oben rein und du hast halt gleich mit einem Gerät zwei. Was halt extrem cool ist, so für dieses Casual-Durchkopieren, du hast so nackte Festplatten, die du immer mal wieder als Backup benutzt, die du aber nicht permanent brauchst und auch nicht permanent schützen musst.
Nackte Festplatten wollen deine Backups.
In deiner Umgebung wollen an deine Daten.
Wollen die an die Daten.
Genau, wollen die an die Daten.
An deinen Daten rumspielen.
Oh, meine Schnitzstelle explodierte vor Lust.
Ungeschützter Datenaustausch.
Es ist keine 090er Podcast.
Erstmal noch.
Es ist kein 090er Podcast hier.
Lass mal genießen, runterschlucken und dann weiterheben.
Da kann ich noch mal kurz zu diesem Jog dazwischen erwähnen. Nur so kurz, er ist magnetisch.
Halt!
Nein.
Max.
Du unterbrichst hart. Pranglerhart.
Also, dieses Dock, hast du da schon mal Probleme gehabt?
Nö.
Kommt also irgendwie mit USB und eSata. Also sollte man sowas haben. Hat man ja natürlich normalerweise nicht, aber wenn man es hat, dann hat man es.
Gibt es nicht Firewire auf eSata?
Demnächst, vielleicht unter Umständen mal irgendwann. Da will ja Belkin jetzt auch diesen Thunderbolt.
Seit wieviel Jahren sprechen wir davon?
Ja, gefühlt sind es schon drei. Gefühlt ist dieses Produkt schon länger angekündigt, als es das Thunderbolt gibt. Und sie überbieten sich jetzt im Vorankündigen und im Preiseverändern und in Spezifikationen ändern. Und ich glaube einfach nix. Und ich hoffe nur dringend und inständig, dass Apple endlich mal einfach einen stinknormalen Thunderbolt auf Gigabit-Ethernet-Adapter rausbringt. Für übliche, handelsübliche 150 Euro oder so. Scheiße. Also Apple Store übliche. Wissen schon. Also auf jeden Fall kann ich jedem, der so im Festplatten-Juggling unterwegs ist, nur dazu raten, diesen Sharkoon-Sata mal zu erwägen, weil das einfach eine extrem praktische Sache ist. Du, ich sehe hier... Kannst du auch noch mal eine kalte Mate irgendwie aus dem Kühlschrank holen, Robb, wo du gerade unterwegs bist? Oder soll ich jetzt auch mit dem Bier anfangen? Oder gib mir einfach mal ein Bier. Ist das noch halbwegs kalt? Bier at random.
Guck mal, Tim.
Ja, es kam heute frisch reingedings, das ist nämlich frisches Bier. Wenn ihr mal drauf schaut, wie lange das haltbar ist. Hier steht zum Beispiel drauf...
Dann bring mir auch noch mal ein mit, damit das hier nicht so schnell... damit das nicht wieder schlecht wird, wie das letzte Mal. Letztes Mal mussten wir ja ganz schlecht das Bier trinken.
Ja, das ist alles noch ganz frisch hier. Das muss jetzt alles weg. Nothelfer heißt das hier.
Was hast du denn da?
Hier gibts einen echt schlanken Adapter Firewire auf SATA, also Firewire 800 auf SATA, von Seagate sogar. Seagate Free Agent Go Flex Upgrade Kabel Firewire 800.
Für 15 Euro.
Go Flex Pro Ultra 2 Slimline Extra Edition.
Hier, komm mal, kannst du... Klick mal auf dem Schirm hier, Tim.
Ja, das sagst du so einfach.
Achso, du kannst ja nicht.
Doch, ich kann, aber ich muss hier erstmal meine Fernbedienung...
Also ich mein...
Das ist ein Drama, das ist echt ein Drama.
Also so eine...
Hammer Hard. Ja, worauf soll ich klicken?
Aber es gibt hier auch Reviews, also einer sagt schlecht.
Das da?
Einer sagt schlechte Geschwindigkeit, andere sagt gute Geschwindigkeit.
Aber Firewire, ich meine, da brauch ich erstmal einen Adapter auf Firewire...
Gibt's auch nicht.
Kann man zu der Apple Fernbedienung auch Bierflaschen öffnen?
Das ist mein Kickstarter-Projekt. Ein iPhone-Ständer, der gleichzeitig als Bier, als Korken, also als Flaschenöffner dient. Als Korkenzieher und Flaschenöffner.
Steckste in den Audioport und dann drehste los.
Das ist natürlich noch besser. Ich meine, das iPhone-Ständer ist ja sowieso. Das gehört doch eigentlich an jede Schweizer Taschenmesser heutzutage dran, oder? Weiß ich vorhin noch mal...
Das ist ja immer wieder...
.in den Chat schon geworfen habe. Das ist ein Link zu dem Twig, den kann ich auch noch mal reinpacken. Das gibt es auch noch nicht. Das ist auch noch ein hübsches Kickstarter-Projekt, wie ich finde. Da gab es noch was anderes, sehr, sehr ähnliches. Auch als Kickstarter-Projekt. Das hier finde ich noch einen Zacken hübscher. Und zwar, das ist ein...
Wir machen das jetzt hier wie in amerikanischen Podcasts. Reden, dummes Zeug.
Du weißt das Unterschied zu vor zehn Minuten?
Danke unseren Spendern. Ich hab jetzt gerade keinen...
Unseren Sponsoren heißt das.
Ja, ich... Das steht wieder mal nicht drauf, von wem es jetzt eigentlich geschickt wurde. Nee, steht aber nicht drauf. Trotzdem, du weißt, wer du bist und...
Wir danken dir.
Dankeschön.
Für dieses Bier. Jedes Mal trinken wir dieses Bier auch...
Zeitgemäß.
Gleichzeitig, genau. Also das ist mir wirklich...
Klickt nochmal auf den Twig da.
Den Twig?
Auf den Twig.
Ja, das ist ein iPhone-Adapter-Kabel mit USB. Das Kabel ist ein bisschen stabiler. Und es hat noch zusätzlich so zwei Arme quasi. Sodass man es, wenn man einen USB-Anschluss hat, in jeder beliebigen Position an dem USB-Anschluss das iPhone anbringen kann. Und dass man es auch zusätzlich noch so ein bisschen als Stativ nutzen kann. Alles so in einem Kabel eingebaut. Bei diesem anderen Ding, da hatten sie nur einen etwas längeren Kabel. Da haben sie es so richtig gedacht, als viele Monitore haben ja heutzutage so einen USB-Anschluss hinten. Dass du da dann einfach so dein iPhone dranhängst, dann kannst du so das iPhone direkt an der Seite dranhängen haben und jederzeit benutzen.
Wie so ein Rückspiegel.
Wie so ein Rückspiegel, genau.
Aber kannst halt nur Porträt...
Das kannst du ja drehen, wie du willst. Das kannst du auch drehen, das ist doch... Ich glaube, das ist nicht fest. Ich glaube, das ist so flexibel. Und wo ich es noch ganz praktisch finde, Fender, das ist so, wenn man iOS-Development macht und dabei seinen Laptop auf dem Schoß hat, so richtig so im Sommer im Garten und auf ein Gerät testen will, dann ist das irgendwie immer doof, weil irgendwie hast du immer das Telefon, da muss du es wieder weglegen und rüberlegen. Und wenn du das über so einen Schwanenhals einfach draußen am Rechner hängen würdest, und du könntest so in Xcode schön arbeiten, Apple Air laufen lassen, dann mal kurz so rübergreifen, ein bisschen testen und dann wieder, das könnte echt ganz praktisch sein.
Du hast es jetzt noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das gibt es noch gar nicht, das ist da ein 3D-Rendering, glaube ich. Sie, die haben 44.000, hatten sie das zu dem Zeitpunkt. Also auch das wären wir. Kickstarter, die Plattform für die Finanzierung von iPhone-Zubehör. Ja, kann ich, also viele tolle Sachen auf Kickstarter, da könnte ich mehrere Monatsgehälter durchbringen. Und kein Cent davon für Kultur ausgeben.
Hängt ganz vom Monatsgehalt ab.
So, das war's eigentlich schon.
Ja, ich mein, wir könnten jetzt noch mal über Abortenleinen herziehen und so, aber es wiederholt sich ja alles.
Und so mal, wir wissen ja nicht, was...
Wir können ein bisschen über underscore.m herziehen. Und du bist ein bisschen Nerdscheiße.
Ja, was ist das?
Für die Kredibilität. Das ist eine Objective-C-Library, die ich geschrieben habe. Und der eine oder andere kennt vielleicht underscore.js, das ist eine JavaScript-Library, die so ein bisschen funktionale Helper-Methoden macht. Und ich hab das quasi nach Objective-C geportet, aber die Syntag ist ein bisschen unkonventionell. Das hat so einen kleinen Shitstorm ausgelöst auf Hacker News.
Was ist daran so unkonventionell?
Du kennst Objective-C. Da hast du ja immer diese eckigen Klammern. Und das ist halt kacke. Wenn du irgendwie chainen willst, weil wenn du irgendwie einen Aufruf hast, wo du eine Funktion aufrufst und noch einen und noch einen und noch einen sammeln sich von hinten diese eckigen Klammern an, wie nichts Gutes. Und was ich gerade gemacht hab, ist ich mach ein Wrapper-Objekt, da tust du dann dein Array rein. Und dieses Wrapper-Objekt hat dann Properties, die Blocks return. Und da kannst du dann mit dieser Dot-Syntax, also kannst einfach schreiben Array.map, dann tust du da dein Block rein, Punkt reduce und so weiter und so fort.
Also die Syntax, die er gebaut hat, die sieht eher so nach JavaScript?
Ich hab im Prinzip JavaScript in Objective-C nachgebaut.
Du hast da eine eigene Syntax plötzlich, also Syntax, die sonst eigentlich überhaupt nicht auftaucht in Objective-C.
Aber dafür kann man es, meiner Meinung nach, ein bisschen besser lesen, als wenn man genau das Gleiche mit Objective-C machen würde, ohne sich da ganz viele Hilfsvariablen zu halten permanent.
Also ich wollte das eigentlich gerne hier mal Roddi zeigen und gucken, ob er vor Begeisterung aufschreit oder vor schockstarre Umfeld. Ich hätte mir beide Reaktionen... also bei mir war es ein bisschen irgendwie schon sehr cool, aber irgendwie auch creepy. Also es ist so ein bisschen merkwürdig. Aber es ist halt so ein Haufen ständig so MapReduce-Funktionen, die man ständig braucht. Also die Beispiele, die du da eingebaut hast, die sind auch echt ganz geil. Hier kriegt Jason Daten rein, schmeißt erstmal alles aus, was nicht ein String ist, weil kann ja sein, dass unsere Daten nicht sauber sind. Und dann gehen wir da, also per Reduce, und dann gehen wir da nochmal Mapping rüber und machen da das und das draus. Und schon haben wir den Twitter-Stream ausgegeben. Es ist möglich, in Objective-C eigene Syntaxen zu basteln.
Mit so ein bisschen... Und das MIT-Leistung.
Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Schon wieder gut.
Du benutzt kein Objective-C, stimmt's?
Nee, ich halte mich fern.
Ich hab mich auch fern gehalten bisher.
Aber ganz lustig ist, wie das gebaut ist. Weil wie kriegt man da so eine eigene Syntax rein? In so eine Sprache, die es eigentlich nicht unterstützt, dass man eine eigene Syntax macht. Die Punkt-Syntax bekommt man ja nur, wenn man Properties hat. Und das sind alles Properties eines Objekts, die in einen Block zurückgehen. Und an diesen Block schmeißt man dann eine Methode. Also direkt per Klammer auf Klammer zu eine Methode hintendran.
Genau, also ein Block in einen Block.
Ich als Purist kann sowas nicht gut heißen. Es klingt so wie, wie dass ich verstehen könnte, warum es da ein Shitstorm auf Hacker News gab.
Ich halte das auch für nachvollziehbar auf. Wenn ich mich da jetzt keiner Meinung anhängen will. Ich meine, manchmal ist es ja auch cool, bestimmte Methodiken anderer Sprachen mal auch einfach so zu benutzen. Du hast da ein MapReduce gemacht.
Und Filter und Plug. Wenn du halt einen Dictionary hast, kannst du dir gleich nur bestimmte Key-Value-Pairs rausholen. Oder du kannst alles rausholen.
Ich begreife überhaupt nicht, was diese Library überhaupt macht.
Du kannst dir mal die Beispiele da aufmachen.
Es ist halt eine Library mit Methoden aus so funktionaler Programmierwelt, mit denen Arrays und Hashes Mappen, Filtern, Folden, Flatten, Shuffeln.
PunktEach ist eine Methode, die auf jeden Objekt deines Arrays einmal gerufen wird. Also du sagst Array.Each und dann wird die gerufen mit jedem Element einmal.
Ach so was gibt's nicht in Objective-C?
Doch, das ist halt so lang. Enumerate, Block with Objects und Options und hast nicht gesehen, Ecke Klammer zu.
Und das ist halt so eine relativ kleine Syntax dafür. Und ein paar Sachen davon gibt's gar nicht. Die muss man dann jedes Mal aufwendig selber schreiben.
Schon ganz praktisch.
Ja, also so eine Libraries an sich sind auf jeden Fall praktisch.
Hans hat schon recht, irgendwie.
Niemals von den Bäumen runterkommen.
Ja, so alt ist Tim jetzt auch noch nicht.
Aber er hat doch gesagt, dass die Lisp-Brand-Time halt einfach scheiße fett und behäbig ist, ne?
Trotzdem hatten sie recht.
Ja, oder was anderes. Aber ich weiß schon, warum es nicht so ist.
Trotzdem ist es mal wieder erstaunlich, dass eigentlich so die Sachen, die 1950 alle schon da waren, auch im Jahre 2012 immer noch mühsam in andere Sprachen hineingetragen werden, wenn man dann eingesehen hat, so nach 60 Jahren, dass das doch nicht so eine schlechte Idee war. Vorher 60 Jahre Shitstorm und so, braucht man doch nicht. Eigentlich gar nicht so doof.
Ich glaube langsam aber sicher wird Objective-C eine vernünftige Sprache. Also jetzt gibt es ja auch mit den Literalen. Das ist schon ein großer Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Also einerseits ja, andererseits habe ich so von außen immer so das Gefühl, dass das halt auch so ein Hodgepodge mehr und mehr wird. So heute ist Garbage Collection mal dran, dann bauen wir das mal ein und dann fällt uns aber auf, dass Garbage Collection wieder doof ist, dann machen wir es so halb aus oder doch, und dann machen wir was anderes. Und dann jetzt machen wir hier noch ein paar neue Syntax-Erweiterungen. Hier anonyme Blogs und irgendwie noch eine Spreading-Line, das wird alles so zusammengeworfen. Aber so der große Visionäre, weiß nicht, also der rote Faden wird so ein bisschen verschwommener.
Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass ihr da jetzt gerade so einfach alles einbaut, was praktisch ist. Man merkt, dass sie mit ihrem LLVM langsam dahin kommen, wo sie hin wollten. Also da gab es ja auch einen ganz spannenden Artikel über LLVM, warum das eigentlich so geil ist und wie das alles funktioniert und was LLVM überhaupt ist. Hat denn jemand von euch diesen Artikel gelesen?
Der CAA ist nicht sonderlich gut zu dem LLVM.
Na ja, vor drei oder vier Jahren war das.
Ich weiß, aber der war so ein bisschen farig. Ich hab versucht, den zu hören, aber der war einer derjenigen Podcasts, wo ich dachte...
Also versucht zu hören.
Ich hab den beides Mal nicht zu Ende gehört.
Vielleicht kann ja jemand mal einen Link zu den Artikeln in den Chat schmeißen, dann können wir den auch einbauen. So wie so die Geschichte von LLVM so ein bisschen ist, was da eigentlich genau läuft.
Ich denk auf was jetzt?
Auf diesen Artikel über LLVM.
Der ging auch über Hacker News.
Der ging überall rum.
Ja, bei mir nicht.
Ich hoffe, im Chat.
Der Artikel.
Ja, es ist so ein...
Ach, der eine Artikel im Internet über ein technisches Thema.
Ach der!
Ja, da gibt es in der Tat einige, aber vielleicht gab es gerade kürzlich...
Hat tatsächlich niemand. Muss ja irgendwo noch mit meinem Pinboard drinne stehen.
Also es war nicht gerade gestern oder heute.
Also ich auf Hacker News Network suche.
Aber es ist schon ein paar Tage her.
Das ist er.
Wenn man die Suche benutzt, schon ist er da.
Siehste, sag ich doch, der Artikel über LLVM.
Jetzt auf der Kinoleinwand. Und Apple ist dran schuld.
Dass du nicht auf den Link klicken kannst.
Also ich weiß jetzt wirklich nicht genau, wer der schuld ist. Ich hab ja diesen Oscillator installiert. Und der installiert ja einen eigenen Treiber, der sich in dieses Bluetooth-Framework einklingt.
Ist das immer noch diese Java-Grütze? Oder verwechsel ich das was?
Das verwechselst du. Das war noch nie Java.
Oscillator.
Für OC Remote-Gedöns. Mir war es so, als wäre es Java.
Diesen nicht Java. Das ist strammes Objective-C, soweit ich das sehe.
Aber ja, wir waren hier gerade bei LVM.
Achso, von Chris Lettner. Vom 29. Mai.
Genau.
Er schreibt mal so, was so Sache ist, sozusagen.
Er schreibt, also was ist denn erstmal so eine Einführung in wie baue ich überhaupt einen Compiler, was für mich jetzt auch durchaus das Neue war. Also was ist ein Frontend, was ist ein Optimizer, was ist ein Backend dahinter. Wie haben das so die klassischen Ansätze gemacht, also GCC und Konsorten, warum ist das scheiße, wesentlichenweise es nicht durchgezogen haben. Und wie hat LVM dieses Problem besser gelöst? Also die haben da so eine Metasprache, also es ist eigentlich mehr als eine Sprache, LLVM-IR, das heißt LLVM Intermediate Representation. Die drei Zustände kennt, nämlich einmal im Speichersein, einmal als Binärformat und einmal als lesbare Sprache. Und das ist so die einzige Sprache, das ist so das einzige, was die alle zwischendurch können. Also das Frontend wandelt das in diese Zwischensprache um, dann kommt die Optimierung hinter, die dann die schönen Sachen raus, also so, die Optimierung zurechtmacht, meinen hässlichen langsamen Code schönmacht und dann kommt das Backend hinten dran, was dann nachher den eigentlichen Code für die jeweilige Plattform produziert. Und das ist offensichtlich tatsächlich wunderbar flexibel. Also zum einen darum, weil wirklich du einfach ein beliebiges Backend vorne an eine beliebige Sprache hinten dranhängen kannst. Also du kannst vorne jede Sprache rein und kommt hinten jeder Code raus, wenn du das entsprechende Backend und Frontend geschrieben hast. Diese müssen nicht aufeinander abgestimmt sein, wie bei GCC zum Beispiel. Und es geht noch weiter, sie können einzelne Module, also Backends können Module haben. Und wenn du dann, also ein x86 ist jetzt auch nicht so großartig was anderes als ein PowerPC, die Optimierung ist drinne, die Optimierung ist drinne, die Optimierung ist drinne, aber das und das und das ist nicht drinne und ich hab eine andere Zahl von Registern, dann brauchst du nur die Teile auszuwechseln, die sich tatsächlich geändert haben. Das klang sehr, sehr, sehr flexibel das ganze Ding. Und das ist, kann man sich einfach mal schön abends durchlesen und dann hat man schon ein bisschen was über LFN gelernt.
Am Kermin mit dem Glas Cognac.
Genau, oder Rotwein alternativ. Was man so acht macht abends.
Das ist immer das schönste, wenn die Leute, die sich das selber mal ausgedacht haben, ein The Design of Text schreiben. Das waren bisher immer die besten Bücher, die so hießen.
Und er spricht auch, also es geht, es ist jetzt alles nicht unglaublich tief, aber er zeigt auch ein bisschen Code. Er sagt auch, was so die Scheiße ist, was man wieder in Rewrite brauchen würde und so was.
Aber er äußert sich hier nur zu LLVM, er äußert sich nicht zu Zählern.
Na Zähler, also ja, das ist, also er beschreibt auch, dass LLVM hat, genau, das ist natürlich auch noch so ein wichtiger Punkt, den ich total vergessen habe, weil LLVM ist ja diese Toolchain, diese komplette, die aus einzelnen kleinen Modulen und Bibliotheken besteht, die man auch nach Belieben nehmen kann und aufsplitten kann. Also man kann durchaus so was machen, man kann Code kompilieren in diese LLVM-IR-Binary-Sprache und dann liefert man nachher, ich glaube, das ist das, was Apple macht und auch andere mit diesen, wir liefern Code so aus, dass er wahlweise, wenn die Grafikkarte schnell genug ist, wird er direkt auf der Grafikkarte aufgeführt und wenn das nicht hinhaut, dann führen wir es halt auf den Prozessor aus, weil da brauchst du nur noch dieses LLVM-Backend hintendran zu hängen. Und das ist relativ klein und du kannst es einfach mit einkompilieren, deinen Code und teilweise den Compiler einfach mit ausliefern, mit deinem Produkt. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, dann ist C-Lang nichts weiter als ein Frontend, quasi ein Kommando-Zahlen-Frontend für so eine da Toolchain, die da einmal so durchgeht. Und davon gibt es noch diverse andere.
Also was heißt nichts weiter?
Das ist natürlich auch ein eigenes Projekt für sich, aber...
Ja, ja, das ist ein mächtiges Projekt und damit sind sie irgendwie auch dieser ganzen GCC-Welt echt enteilt.
Das ist echt erstaunlich.
Und darüber können sie auch so Features machen, weil wenn das Frontend vorne die Syntax-Analyse schon mal macht und das nicht hinten der Compiler machen muss, dann kannst du den auch rausnehmen, kannst den in deinen Editor einbauen und dann zeigt er dir erstmal schon die Syntax-Fehler an, ohne dass du jedes Mal so einen kompletten Durchlauf machen musst. Das ist schon...
Vor allem ist es derselbe Parser. Also es ist nicht etwas, was so ähnlich ist, sondern es ist exakt genau so ein Fehler, der beim Compilen gefunden wird. Der wird dann auch im Editor schon gefunden.
Und ich glaube, das ist das, was wir jetzt gerade so mitkriegen, mit Xcode, mit diesen Literals und mit Arc und Konsorten, dass sie einfach... Jetzt haben sie ihren LL-Form soweit, dass sie jetzt die Maschine warmlaufen lassen können und eigentlich so das machen können, was sie ganz Zeit wollen. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass sie da schon einen großen Plan hinter haben. Und hier so mit den Blöcken, das ist... Das möchte man ja eigentlich... Also ich möchte Objective-Scene nicht ohne Blöcke programmiert haben.
Ich sag ja auch nicht, dass die Features schlecht sind. Das ist nur so, so fühlt so manchen, die da alles auf dieses Objective-Scene noch drauf. Einfach nur so. Das nimmt an Schwung, was er aufsammt, mal.
Aber ich mein, jetzt mit dem ganzen LVM-Kram wär's ja nicht so schwer, mal zu sagen, wir nehmen ein anderes Frontend mit einer anderen Sprache. Das gab's ja vor kurzem dieses Ruby-Motion. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt.
Also hast du so eine Aktion gesehen?
Ich hab mir eine Lizenz bestellen lassen auf Arbeit, aber die ist glaub ich noch nicht da. Aber die Idee ist halt, dass du in Ruby iOS-Apps programmieren kannst mit ganz wenig Aufwand.
Der macht dann das mit Arc und so, da läuft dann noch so ein Präprozessor drüber, der dann...
Genau, das ist irgendwie eine Variante von Ruby, die statisch kompiliert wird. Aber du hast dann auch so Nettigkeiten wie eine Konsole, wo du dann in Realtime während dein Simulator offen ist, deine Views hin und her schieben kannst. Was ziemlich interessant sein kann.
Das ist der Teil, den ich auch ganz gerne... Wobei, das könnten sie eigentlich auch schaffen mit... Das müsste doch auch so gehen.
Nee, du kannst das bauen.
Also, kann man das nicht mal für Objective-C bauen?
Nee, du müsstest einfach irgendwie Message Send aufrufen und irgendwie da so einen Webserver laufen lassen, den du dann Jason shakes und der macht dann ein Message Send draus.
Oder über einen Debugger dich reinhängen. Der Debugger hängt doch drin.
Oder Objective-C-Script, ein Interpreter für Objective-C-Bauen.
Woher wissen die eigentlich, wie man Robb schreibt? Im Chat?
Haben wir das nicht gesagt?
Hast du bestimmt gesagt.
Das klingt man ja auch.
Das hört man ja.
Steht das nicht auf der Anderscore-M-Seite?
Das kann sein, aber ich glaube, ich hab's vorher schon gesehen, bevor ich hier diese Produktplatzierung untergebracht hab.
Ah, der Chat, der ist da ganz finnig da.
Kann auch sein, dass ich das immer gesagt habe. Robb mit 2B.
Das ist sogar live als live. Die Hörer sind uns quasi voraus.
Ich hab vorhin schon gesagt, die hören das 10 Minuten, bevor wir das überhaupt sprechen.
Genau, die Robb-Kopie ist schon...
Die haben schon abgeschaltet, bevor wir fertig sind.
Die Robb-Kopie.
Koko-Pots.
Robb-Kopie.
Robb-Step.
Hab ich noch nichts mitgemacht, hast du damit schon was gemacht? Uri scheint da ganz begeistert von zu sein.
Ja, das ist ganz cool. Das ist halt so ein gemmäßiges Library-Management.
Auf der Yoruko war auch so ein Typ, der da eine Präsentation drüber gehalten hat.
Die machen das auch mit Rake oder so was, ne?
Scheint ganz gut zu sein, weil momentan ist es schon ein bisschen schwierig und Getsup Modules haben ihr eigenes Problem.
Ihr eigenes Leben, ja. Also wenn die Talks von der Yoruko 2012 online sind, da gibt es dann auch einen Talk mit Frauenchor, der da über Koko-Pots spricht. Die Gesangseinlage kommt erst zum Schluss, also am Anfang spricht ja über das Proler.
Gut, dann guck ich mir auf jeden Fall an. Weil mich Koko-Pots interessieren. Das ist auch relativ simpel. Ich glaube, man sollte mit einem leeren Projekt anfangen, am besten, oder? Weil da liegt dann diese Xcode-Workspaces noch dazu an.
Da könnte Apple mal was machen. Also dieses ganze Project-File-Mage.
Ach da, da heulen auch unsere Entwickler die ganze Zeit rum.
Sowas von Broken, das gibt es überhaupt nicht.
Das ist auch so ein Phänomen im 21. Jahrhundert, was ich öfters beobachte, dass so Tools und Toolchains einfach so richtig doll Broken sind und richtig Schmerzen bereiten, aber niemand fixt das. Also die haben so Schmerz, wie sagt man, renitent?
Resistent.
Resistent, dass dann auch keiner da was tut. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich diese iOS-Entwickler bei uns beobachte, es gibt wirklich täglich mindestens einen Fluchmoment bei jedem dieser Entwickler, wo er so richtig so, oh fick, da hab ich doch Apple, mit dem Keyboard in der Hand, wem buchtet. Einmal am Tag hat das jeder von denen. Siehst du, genau.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, da weiß ich, okay, Xcode hat jetzt eine halbe Sekunde nichts mehr gemacht, ich kann mein Getränk holen gehen. Gerade, wenn man so ein Pop-Up aufmacht am unteren Rand des Bildschirms und es geht über die Scroll-Leiste, dann schmier ich es erstmal ab.
Das ist wirklich, Xcode kennt mehrere Zustände des Abstürzens.
Der fragt dich, ob hier alles unerwartet ist, soll ich crashen oder willst du weitermachen?
Meistens kann man problemlos weitermachen. Ich hab das Gefühl, dass z.B. Autocompletion, dass die einfach mal zwischendurch durchtickt. Du fängst an zu tippen, dann kriegst du ein Menü präsentiert, in dem du auswählen kannst, welche Methode du aufrufen möchtest. Dann hat er sich verschluckt, sich regelmäßig mal und interpretiert einen Cursor nach unten drücken. Beide Male, einmal im Editor und einmal im Menü, sodass du nicht mehr auswählen kannst, den Menüpunkt, den du haben willst. Manchmal ist das einfach nur, weil die Syntax im konkreten Fall gerade nicht hundertprozentig gestimmt hat. Manchmal ist es auch, dass sich Xcode pauschal verschluckt hat und dass nur ein Neustart hilft von Xcode. Aber darüber hinaus ist eigentlich auch viel Gutes dabei. Es ist nicht alles schlecht. Es ist Jammern auf hohem Niveau. Ich glaube, das ist schon was anderes als mit Text. Mait hat auch seine Fehler. Vim ist mir noch nie abgeschmeckt, glaube ich. Ja, aber für kann es auch nichts.
Na ja, kann man eh nichts machen, außer so etwas wie App-Code zu benutzen im Zweifel.
Man kann auch für Sublime. Gibt es hier auch eine Klangintegration mit Objective-C-Unterstützung?
Taugt ihr was? Aber hätten wir es auch geklärt.
Darum gibt es so wenig gute Apps im App-Store. Die Leute sind viel zu beschäftigt, mit den Tools zu kämpfen.
Na jetzt wo es Through-Emotion gibt, da können wir das jetzt... Ich glaube, das hat seine ganz eigenen Schmerzen. Wobei das Testing soll auch ganz schön sein neben der...
Ja also Testing ist ja auch so ein großes Problem. Da kann ich ja ein Lied von singen.
Das ist auch ein Auslöser für viele dieser WTF-Momente gewesen schon.
Was benutzen die bei VUGA zum Testen?
Weiß ich nicht, was sie aktuell benutzen. Die haben da schon vieles ausprobiert.
Hat alles nichts geholfen?
Ich weiß nicht. Also sie haben sie jetzt auf irgendwas eingeschossen. Wir haben jetzt sogar Automatic Continuous Integration. Ja, aber war ein langer Kampf. Aber wie sie es genau machen, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Da wäre ich aber mal interessiert.
Na ja, dann kommst du mal bei VUGA vorbei, so als alter Soundcloud-Mitarbeiter.
Mach ich mal.
Kannst du da ruhig mal, wir haben, ja, kannst du mal vorbeikommen. Gut, Tim, dein Einsatz.
Ich hab schon seit einer Viertelstunde kein Thema mehr.
Du hast jetzt die ganze Zeit im Internet gesucht.
Du hast seit zweieinhalb Stunden kein Thema mehr.
Ich sag ja, dieses Apple-Thema, das zieht einfach nicht mehr.
Ist ja auch so.
Zeit für was Neues.
Was denn? Wer denn, wo denn, wann denn?
Ja, weiß ich nicht, das ist ja das generelle Dilemma. Vielleicht sollte man einfach diesen ganzen Komplex Internet und Computer einfach mal wechseln.
Ja, oder wir machen selber, ne?
Wir machen Kickstarter und dann selber einen Computer bauen. Ich muss weg. Nee, ich dachte einfach mal was handwerkliches.
Rosen züchten. Laubsäge arbeiten.
Gartenarbeit, wir können uns auch mal darüber unterhalten. Ich säge jetzt Laub.
Ja, ich war gerade in Amsterdam, da gab es auch sehr schöne Tulpenzwiebelangebote. Also von groß bis klein für jeden Geschmack passt dabei.
Du hättest mal was mitgebracht.
Ja, aber die Tulpensaison ist ja jetzt auch schon vorbei.
Ist egal, die haust du jetzt rein, nächstes Frühjahr geht es ab.
Hast du Drogen mitgebracht aus Amsterdam?
Nee, die hab ich alle aufgegessen.
Drogen aus Amsterdam.
Ich war auch in Holland und ich hab auch keine Drogen mitgebracht.
Das ist da auch mittlerweile alles.
Nee, also ich war in einem Coffee-Shop da und der meinte, also an der Grenze, da ist schwierig, aber wenn du es bis Amsterdam geschafft hast, dann ist alles cool. Also bei uns gab es da keine Probleme. Beim Wahnaustausch.
Ah, das ist sehr gut zu wissen. So, Chet.
Der Tim, der kann nicht mehr.
Gibt es noch Themen?
Der guckt auch schon ganz glasig.
Ja, ich bin ein bisschen...
Das Bier haut rein.
Ja, das Bier ist extrem nett. Extrem süffig. Ja, das ist süffig und das ist wirklich auch sehr... Hier steht drauf, würzig frisch. Nothelfer. Lager. Würzig frisch.
Also ich hab hier einen... Weißen... Weißen Nohr Klosterbrauerei. Ein Kloster-Sut. Das klingt auch so ein bisschen merkwürdig, aber schmeckt doch ganz gut.
Ich hab einen Hübner-Breu und das handelt sich dabei in meinem Vollbier.
Wow.
Was auch immer das heißt.
Das ist alles Vollkorn, Gerste und Hopfen.
Jetzt wird mir das gerade erst so richtig gewahrt. Es ist wirklich lecker.
Ja.
Also so richtig lecker. Enthält Wasser, Gersten, Malz, Hopfen.
Dann wär's auch kein Bier.
Toll. Ganz toll.
Das sagt ja einer Tannenzäpfle, das Tannenzäpfle, ich mag das nicht. Das ist zu sauer.
Ich mag das ganz gut.
Das hat zu viel Säure. Davon kann ich nicht viel trinken. Danach krieg ich gleich so...
Aua.
Aua?
Nee, irgendwie so Sodbrennen, keine Ahnung, irgendwie so Magensäure.
Wo ich's gerade von mir sehe.
Da wird nach Streaming gefragt. Also, wir haben darüber gesprochen hier, WWDC und so. Ich mein, wir haben da jetzt diverse Leute vor Ort. Max hat ja auch sein Mikrofon am Start.
Live aus der Keynote.
Ah, aber so mit live und so, keine Ahnung. Also, ich werd da nicht zuarbeiten können, weil ich... Wenn ich Glück hab, kann ich mir die Keynote...
Können wir ein Hörer-Treffen machen? Das wär doch lustig.
Das können wir machen.
San Francisco, Hörer-Treffen in San Francisco.
Ja, das wär doch mal lustig. Wenn's da welche gibt.
Ja klar, gibt's...
Ich hab gerade versucht, ein Hörer-Treffen in Rom zu machen und nichts. Ja, also Tumbleweed und Crickets.
Auf dieser Apple-Konferenz, da sind bestimmt keine Mobile. Keine Mobile, Max Hörer. Also überall, da bestimmt nicht.
Nee, aber ich kann mir die Keynote... Also wenn du sie mir live überträgst, dann krieg ich sie auch live mit.
Du weißt, dass du nur aus der Keynote übertragen darfst. Alles anderes NDA. Also du darfst eigentlich nur über die Keynote was erzählen.
Ich meine, ich kann ja mit Entwicklern da außerhalb berichten und man kann ja abends mal... Wie macht man das jetzt am besten mit... Ich weiß jetzt nicht, an welchem Tag sich am besten einigt hier.
Also das Problem ist, ich bin...
Also Soundcloud macht ne Party und...
Soundcloud macht ne Party?
Ja.
Wann denn?
Entweder am Mittwoch oder am Montag, glaube ich. Das kann man noch mal irgendwie veröffentlichen und da...
Da bei denen oder hier?
In San Francisco in ner Bar. Und da kann man bestimmt gerne vorbeikommen.
Genau. Da sauf mal Soundcloud das Venture-Kapital weg.
Ich hatte immer mein Mikrofon aus.
Wir haben ja noch gar nicht über Soundcloud geredet.
Ach, da gibt's doch nicht viel Zeit.
Na, was mich immer so ein bisschen wundert ist...
Wir richten den Termin noch nach.
Also ich weiß ja jetzt gar nicht, inwieweit das überhaupt in deinen Bereich fällt, aber was ist denn mit... dieses Ding mit Soundcloud und Podcasting?
Mit Soundcloud und Podcasting. Es gibt Podcasts auf Soundcloud. Es gibt mehrere Podcasts.
Es gibt da manche, die da tatsächlich das da mitmachen.
Und das ist halt ein Feature, das momentan bestimmten Parteien vorbehalten ist. Aber kann man machen.
Achso, na dann.
Das war jetzt sehr ausführlich auch. Das ist wie gesagt, ist schon nicht mein Departement, aber es gibt schon Leute, die das benutzen.
Ja, aber es gibt auch da diese alberne Geschichte, mit man zahlt für die Zeit, die man da speichert. Das heißt, umso länger man redet, umso teurer wird es.
Richtig.
Zumal, du meinst, weil es Voice-encoded ist, also Voice optimiert encoded und gar nicht so viel Platz verbraucht wie ein gleichwertiges Musikstück.
Ja, aber das ist ja, wir wollen die Leute dazu animieren, möglichst hochqualitatives Audiomaterial hochzuladen. Ja, aber ich meine, so teuer ist jetzt so ein Pro-Account auch nicht.
Ja nun, aber ich meine, was mich fragt, also was heißt das Podcasts? Heißt das, ich kann meine Audio-Datei da ablegen oder kann ich da auch einen Podcast veröffentlichen?
Du kriegst einen RSS-Feed, den kannst du auch in ein Altchen schmeißen.
Nur RSS?
Ja, also ich erinnere mich dunkel vor Jahren, mich mit dem komischen iTunes RSS-Extension FUBAR auseinandergesetzt zu haben. Und das geht auf alle Fälle. Ob Atom-Support ist, kann ich jetzt aus dem Steckreff nicht sagen, aber lässt sich bestimmt alles machen.
Klar lässt sich das machen.
Und du hast beim Comments, Checker-Embets und so, das ist schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, naja ich...
Aber sicher mit den 240 Gratis-Minuten wirst du nicht weit kommen mit deinem Podcast.
Ja, also das ist einfach vollkommen an der Zielgruppe vorbei und ich brauche auch keine Audiowellen, also da ist keine Information enthalten in dem Sinne.
Aber die Kommentarfunktion wäre geil für Podcasts. Also die ist wirklich, so dieses jede beliebige Stelle kommentieren können und dann die eingeblendet sehen, das finde ich zum Beispiel ganz cool.
Findest du das wirklich praktisch?
Wenn man eine beliebige Stelle kommentieren kann, das ist schon praktisch.
Ja, eine beliebige Stelle kommentieren können, da habe ich gar nichts gegen. Aber die Art und Weise, wie das da realisiert ist, finde ich jetzt nicht praktisch.
Das könnte man noch ein bisschen besser machen, ohne Frage, aber es ist ein Ansatz. Also ich meine, andere haben das gar nicht. Kennst du irgendeine Alternative dazu, die das kann, beliebige Stellen? Ich glaube, das geht nicht mal bei YouTube, dass du sagen kannst, hier Stelle, Minute 3, 48, ist besonders toll.
Du kannst jetzt einen Link reinpappen, aber wenn du es abspielst, erscheint es nirgends. Jetzt hast du ja auf Soundcloud gekommen, hast ja dieses Pop-up, das dann vor der Waveform erscheint. Und auf Next, ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast, dem neuen JavaScript-driven Soundcloud, das jetzt in der Public Beta ist, da kannst du dann...
Was das widgett jetzt, der Player, der so von Länge art...
Ne, ne, es gibt die komplette Website.
Es gibt eine komplett neue. Geh mal auf next.soundcloud.com in deinem Lieblingsbrowser auf Choice. Und dann siehst du da...
Dann siehst du hier...
Und dann siehst du da jetzt alles. Gelegt ja immer wieder herrlich hier. Und da hast du dann auch ein bisschen, das ist nicht mehr so in your face mit dem Pop-up, sondern erscheint das einfach unter der Waveform.
Nicht so in your face.
Das ist Private Beta.
Ich hab überhaupt ja keinen Soundcloud-Account.
Nicht vorbereitet diese Journalisten hier. Das soll Qualitätsjournalismus sein. Qualitätsjournalismus? Oder den Beta-Account? Das ist ganz hübsch. Was ich auf der einen Seite total geil finde, was auf der anderen Seite auch ganz schön nervt, ist, wenn man irgendwie anfängt, was zu spielen auf Soundcloud, war man bisher einfach immer irgendwo anders hin zu surfen und dann war es vorbei. Und jetzt ist da so ein Continuous Player drinne, der auch, wenn du die Seite wechselst, weiter spielt, was natürlich total geil ist.
Und das funktioniert sogar across tabs. Also wenn du in Tab A was spielst und in Tab B was startest, dann geht Tab A aus.
Ah, okay, das ist wirklich cool. Aber ich hab da noch nie den schnellen Stop-Button gefunden, mit dem man dann einfach mal so...
Du musst oben auf die Waveform klicken. Dann kommst du direkt auf den Track und da kannst du an Pause drücken.
Da sollten noch irgendwelche Player-Buttons eingebaut werden.
Oder du kannst auch die Leertaste benutzen, immer. Das ist komplett mit Keyboard und...
Ja, da geht schon was. Das macht schon was her. Ist mittlerweile auch gar nicht mehr langsam.
Reicht zumindest das Gefühl.
Sieht kein fancy aus. Aber ich merke bloß immer nur, der Musik- und Podcast-Bedarf, der ist doch schon sehr unterschiedlich. Aber so grundsätzlich, so interaktivere Player, die Kontext haben, das ist auf jeden Fall die Zukunft.
Es gibt natürlich auch einen ganz netten API, von daher kannst du natürlich Soundcloud als Audio-Hosing-Bagent nehmen und dir deine eigene Tim Pridlove-Privat-App zusammenschneidern, die dann das Audio-Material von Soundcloud.
Skaliert natürlich die Scheiße. Wenn nicht gerade jemand die Trextable droppt.
So. Also das wird nichts mit live übertragen aus San Francisco. Das kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen. Ich bin sowieso die nächste Woche im Wesentlichen unterwegs. So wie ihr, nur anders.
Hast du denn ein Headset Adapter und so ein Zock dabei? Dass ich mir das mal mitnehmen kann.
Wie meinst du das dabei?
Na, hier. Ja, wollte ich doch.
Ach so. Da müssen wir gleich noch mal drüber nachdenken.
Dann machen wir das.
Haben wir sonst noch was Produktives beizutragen hier zu dieser Sendung eigentlich?
Huckel? Jetzt mit Produktiv anfangen.
Fällt dir noch irgendwas ein?
Warum die Hörer so unerwartet schockieren?
Sonst können wir die Hörer ja auch mal entlasten.
Ja, also ich überleg, aber nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich gucke, habe ich hier gerade noch irgendwie schöne Apps finden, die ich noch mal so vorstellen könnte?
Robb schüttelt auch mit dem Kopf.
Also, ich glaube, die Sendung können wir mal getrost Peak Mobile Max nennen, oder?
Dann habe ich ja noch Glück gehabt.
Ach so, ich habe ja noch, ich habe ja wieder Informationen bekommen.
Schon wieder ein Vögelchen dir ins Ohr gekäckert.
Welcher Apple Store in Berlin macht denn diesmal nicht auf?
Aber ich kann da jetzt gar nicht so viel zu sagen zu diesen Informationen. Das werde ich euch gleich sagen, warum ich da nicht so viel zu sagen kann. Wie auch immer, wir bedanken uns für die lustre Teilnahme für das Co-Erstellen von Show Notes. Ich hoffe sehr, dass das wieder stattgefunden ist.
Vielen Dank für Speise und Trank.
Wir sind in zwei Wochen wieder dabei. Ihr kommt auf Themenvorschläge und Ende. Dann mit exklusiven, heißen Insights. Ich hoffe, ihr packt dann einfach aus.
Ich bin gar nicht da. Max muss alleine gegen seinen NDA verstoßen.
Ja, genau. Max, du erzählst dann einfach alles. Wir liefern dich danach auch direkt wieder in die USA aus.
Hose runter!
Achso, dann bin ich so der Julian Assange von Moabamax.
Der Bradley Manning bist du.
Dringe ich dann hier so eine Lady Gaga CD an?
Genau, her mit den Daten und dann ab in den Knast mit dir.
Noch schön den USA-Adapter.
Alles für die Hörer, das ist das Motto hier in der Mitte.
Alles für den Dackel, alles für den Klub.
Und richte Apple aus, dass es so nie weitergeht.
Ja, also wenn du immer den Tim Cook auf dem Klo erwischst, dann nimm den mal vor.
Was habt ihr hingegen Cook? Der ist doch, der ist doch...
Habt ihr das Interview gesehen?
Ja, ich hab dieses Interview gesehen. Ich hab das Interview in Ausschnitten gesehen, wie glaube ich alle das nur in Ausschnitten gesehen haben, außer die, die da waren. Aber irgendwann wollen sie es doch vielleicht mal veröffentlichen.
Ja, so ein halbes Jahr später. Das dauert ewig bei denen.
Ach, die veröffentlichen das?
Du kannst es ja dann über Developer-Webseite runterladen.
Nee, das Interview mit Rossink ist nicht hier.
Wir reden jetzt nicht von der WWDC, wir reden von diesem DC-Interview.
Das sind leider nur Ausschnitte, da lassen die sich immer ewig viel Zeit damit.
Aber wenn das schon die Highlights waren, ich meine, was hat er denn gesagt? Dass Ping scheiße ist? Das haben wir auch schon ein paar Tage vorher bei MobileMakes gesagt.
Also was ich ja tatsächlich zu kritisieren fand, war, dass er bei Apple TV so drauf zu bestehen, dass sie ja den voll tollen Content haben und dass Siri ja von den Usern geliebt wird und ganz perfekt funktioniert. Da hätte man ruhig schon mal sagen können, ja, das funktioniert. Also hat er ja im Endeffekt auch gesagt, aber am Anfang so drauf zu bestehen, nee, das ist voll toll. Und dann so, ja, aber warte mal hier die nächsten paar Wochen ab, was da so kommt, da haben wir auch ganz tolle Sachen. Und in dem Moment, in dem er vorher gesagt hat, ja, das ist voll toll, dann nimmt man eben natürlich das, ja warte mal, was in ein paar Wochen kommt, das ist voll toll, nicht mehr so richtig ab. Und ich glaube, da wär Steve schon echt souveräner gewesen. Also das war noch nicht so seine Stärke. Da hätte der ja so, ja, Siri ist ein Experiment, bla bla bla, es ist bei den Usern beliebt, aber noch lange nicht so gut wie sonst denken, aber das ist kontinuierliche Arbeit. Palim, palim, palim, palim, palim.
Steve hat ja auch ganz schön über Mobile Me hergezogen, wenn ich mich mal erinnere.
Stimmt, genau, das ist, ich meine, wenn es nicht so schön zu reden gibt, dann hat er auch nicht schön, also ich meine, er hat tausende Dinge schön geredet, die nicht schön zu reden waren, aber... Ja, okay, das ist...
Ping ist dead.
Ich glaub das.
Aber Ping war auch dead on arrival.
Der war dead on arrival, oh jaja, das war's. Aber sehr.
Aber mit Lady Gaga Featuring immerhin bei der Präsentation.
Ich krieg heute noch gelegentlich Ping-Anfragen. Ich glücklicherweise nicht. Kann man den Account auch wieder löschen?
Kannst du eine Appy ID löschen? Ich glaube nicht. Du kannst dich nicht mal mergen. Also es ist doch deine Apple ID, oder?
Was da mittlerweile alles dranhängt.
Aber ich mein, wenn sie irgendwann mal eine Facebook-Integration haben, dann können sie auch einfach Ping zu dem machen, was es immer sein sollte.
Ping ist einfach Quatsch.
Ping ist wirklich totaler Quatsch.
Apple und das Internet?
Mh-mh. Mh-mh.
Also...
Können die nicht.
Ping, das bildet einfach auch gar keine Realität ab. Das ist... Was ist das? Das ist ein... Kauf-Zettel-Beleg-Poster. Das ist so, als ob ich meine Kauf-Bongs scanne und auf Facebook poste. So ist das irgendwie.
Ich muss mal eben eine Domain registrieren.
Ich glaub, das war so, wie Steve Jobs sich ein Social-Network vorgestellt hat.
Ich kenne niemanden, der mit Siri irgendwas anderes macht, als seine Eieruhr zu purmieren.
Das war eine Facebook-Integration und dann hat Facebook gesagt, vergesst es.
Meinst du, ist Facebook das gesagt oder hat Apple das gesagt?
Ich bin nicht so sicher, dass Facebook gesagt hat, vergesst es.
Hast du ein Vögelchen gehört? Robb hat mit den Augenbrauen gezuckt. Wir interpretieren das jetzt als ein definitives Ja und damit auch als NDA-Verstoß.
Wird auch gleich ausgeliefert.
Wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche in Berlin.
Die überhalten dich gleich Dada, Kopatino.
Wenn die nicht jetzt so ein MacBook Air auf den Tisch legen, wo mal eine SIM-Karte reingeht und...
Ja, Zeit wird's.
Ja, also dann können sie einfach auch einpacken. Ich meine, dann können sie auch ihren Scheiß-TV gleich in der Verpackung lassen. Die dürfen damit einfach gar nicht mehr rauskommen. Auch dieses iPad wird einfach verboten. Ich verbiete das einfach.
Du bist ein Dekret.
Erstmal wird hier das R wirklich zu so einem luftigen Gerät.
Dann lassen wir den Berglöwen auch erstmal im Dorf, ne?
Der Koch muss den Berglöwen im Dorf lassen.
Den Schneelöwen im Dorf, sorry.
Schneelöwen, Berglöwen. Mountain Lion, das ist alles auch. Und diese ganze Katzenkram, das können sie sich jetzt auch schenken. Ich meine, ich kann das jetzt nicht mehr sehen.
Sea Lion.
Sie wiederholen sich ja auch. Also nur noch alternative Namen für, was kommt als nächstes? Ozzelot? Lollcat fand ich ja noch ganz. Geil. So läuft's.
Gut, da muss ja langsam mal US-11 kommen, ne?
Ja, Zeit wird's.
Also ich meine, viel Zeit haben sie nicht mehr.
Kommt nicht.
10.10? Ich meine...
Keine Ahnung, was weiß. Ich hab auch so das Gefühl, dass uns das Lachen dieses Jahr noch kräftig im Hals stecken wird.
Ich meine, spätestens über nächstes Jahr ist es vorbei. Dann ist... nächstes Jahr kommt 10.9, dann kommt... über nächstes Jahr kommt ein...
10.10, ne?
10.10 oder 11 oder aber doch immer. Mal sehen, ob du das noch durchhält. Du hast schon so viele Freunde gehustet.
Ach, der wird sich noch eine Weile machen.
Weil Steve damals auch gedacht hat.
So, ja, ich jammer auf hohem Niveau. Man soll mich doch mal eine Woche vor Windows setzen, meint gerade der Chat. Ja, das war. Ich hab fünf Minuten davor gesetzt. Aber jetzt machen wir hier wirklich mal Schluss, bevor wir das hier noch vollkommen verschleppen. Und wir danken den armen MacBookscom.
Genau, und wie wäre der Slogan jetzt noch mal zum Schluss?
Eine gute Idee muss ein Geheimnis sein, weil es der NDA ist.
Oder so. Oder? Was ist noch jemand?
Da ist gerade noch mal ein Vortrag. Jetzt fragen sie beim Einlass.
Aber werden wir mal so ein bisschen womit interpretiert? Das ist ja bestimmt, dass man automatisch an irgendwelchen Orten bestimmte Aktionen auslöst.
In die WWDC Sachen darfst du nichts reininterpretieren. Das kannst du nur bei diesen Announcements machen.
Ich weiß noch, als Tim hier saß und bei der iPad-Ankündigung bei der ersten iPad-Ankündigung darüber, da war so eine Farbpalette draufgemalt und du dann die Vermutung geäußert hast, dass das iPad ein Loch haben könnte, wo man es halten drin kann.
Ehrlich gesagt, hätte ich es ja fast erwartet.
Da war ich noch nicht dabei, oder?
Das war keine besonders akkurate Vorhersage.
Prähistorisch.
Habt ihr da irgendwie so ein Leaderboard, der die besten Vorhersagen hatte über die Jahre?
Seitwürz?
Jetzt muss ich über jemand anderen...
Hör ich da eine Initiativbewerbung?
So, der Stream ist sowieso schon aus. Stell dich gerade fest, dann können wir die Sendung beenden. Ich fass auch nicht, dass hier diese Tastatur elend ist.
Jetzt kann ich dir meinen ganzen Geheimnisse erzählen.
Ja, genau. Naja, jetzt machen wir erstmal die Sendung zu Ende.
Tschüssikowski! Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.